Hallo, hier ist Chaos Radio Express Ausgabe Nr. 80. Wieder mal ist ein Zehner Schritt genommen. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch zu dieser neuen hoffentlich super informativen Folge. Wir schreiben den 16. März 2008. Und ja, heute könnte es grotesk werden. Das ist auf jeden Fall einer der kleinen Unterthemen, die wir unter Umständen streifen werden. Denn heute möchte ich mit euch in Technikgeschichte eintauchen und zwar ganz spezifisch in die Technikgeschichte des Drucks, des Druckens oder des Wiedergebens von Buchstaben. Man könnte auch sagen Typografie, was nun die korrekte Bezeichnung dafür ist und was dahinter steckt. Das verrät uns heute der Gast. Ich begrüße Thomas, Thomas Maier. Hallo. Hallo. Du bist Student nicht mehr lange, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Genau.
Wie lange wird denn das noch dauern? Wie lange bist du noch Student?
Ich hoffe mal, dass ich es dieses Jahr fertig bringe.
Und was hast du studiert?
Ich habe eigentlich ursprünglich eine Grafika-Ausbildung, dann auf einer Kunstuni und jetzt noch eine kulturwissenschaftliche Dissertation dran gehängt.
Deine Spezialität oder beziehungsweise das Thema, was du dir für deine Diplomarbeit ausgesucht hast, ist die gedruckte Schrift. Genau. Wir haben jetzt hier schon im Vorfeld ein bisschen darüber besprochen. Das heißt, es geht hier eigentlich jetzt im weiteren Sinne um Typografie. Aber eine der interessanten Feststellungen, die wir jetzt vorab schon mal gemacht haben, oder die ich zumindest gemacht habe, dir war das natürlich schon vorher klar, ist, dass das, was man heutzutage eigentlich unter Typografie versteht, etwas ganz anderes ist, als noch vor einiger Zeit es gewesen ist.
Wörtlich ist ja Typografie das Drucken von Typen. Und das ist eben genau das, was Gutenberg erfunden hat. Also den Buchdruck, wie er auch gern noch heute genannt wird.
Was steckt denn eigentlich drin in diesem Wort? Also woher kommt das?
Also das Verfahren, das Gutenberg hier erfunden hat, ist ja weniger eben der Buchdruck, obwohl es oft so bezeichnet wird, sondern die Herstellung der Druckbuchstaben. Also das Gießen der Drucktypen. Und dazu wurde eben, und es wurde auch zum Teil bis 1950, 1970 noch so gemacht, in ein kleines Stahlstückchen, etwa 7 cm hoch, der Buchstabe hinein geschnitten mit verschiedensten Werkzeugen, dieser Stahlstempel, sogenannte Stahlstempel, in eine Kupfermatriz abgedrückt und dann abgegossen. Und von diesen abgegossenen Bleilettern wurde gedruckt. Also wichtig daran ist der dreistufige Herstellungsprozess. Deswegen wird das auch von vielen Wirtschaftstheoretikern als Geburtsstunde der Industrialisierung gesehen, weil eben dieser Herstellungsprozess neu war.
Bevor wir da jetzt noch mal im Detail eingehen, wollte ich noch mal ein bisschen weiter zurückblättern, um diese Entwicklung auch noch ein bisschen im Kontext zu sehen, weil bevor jetzt der Bedarf bestand, industriell zu kopieren, hat sich natürlich über eine sehr, sehr lange Zeit, kulturgeschichtlich, überhaupt erst mal die Schrift entwickelt. Bis man auf die Idee kam, Buchstaben zu drucken, musste natürlich der Buchstabe auch erst mal entwickelt werden. Seit wann gibt es eigentlich Buchstaben in dem Sinne, dass man die irgendwie druckt? Also ich meine, ist das eigentlich nur so ein Phänomen der westlichen Hemosphäre? Man denkt ja mal erst mal an Keilschrift oder irgendwie an Hieroglyphen. Das ist natürlich eine totale Bildersprache, wo ja eigentlich sehr viel mehr mit Assoziation gearbeitet wird, aber nicht so wirklich dieses, ich breche ein Wort auf in seiner einzelnen Teile und dann habe ich immer wiederkehrenden...
Das ist natürlich nicht genau mein Thema, aber prinzipiell ist eben klarerweise jede Schrift am Anfang mal eine Zeichenschrift, also so wie eben A wie Alev, der Ochse, und das wurde dann eben über den venezischen, lateinischen, griechischen Umweg irgendwann unser A. Aber eben direkt vor Gutenberg gab es natürlich Handschriften und die wurden auch in Schreibstuben in größerem Maß bereits hergestellt. Und Gutenberg versuchte im Prinzip genau diese handgeschriebenen Bücher mit einem technischen Prozess zu vervielfältigen.
Schreibstuben, das heißt, wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Da war dann irgendwie so ein Geschäft, wie so ein Schuhmacher und da hat man dann einfach Druckwerke bzw. nicht Schreibwerke in Auftrag gegeben.
Ganz genau, also früher war das natürlich Deskriptorium im Kloster, wo eben dann Mönche für Gottes Lohn die Bücher abgeschrieben haben. Aber sobald es dann eben ein bisschen ein Geschäft wurde, dann gab es Schreibstuben.
Das heißt, die Mönche waren sozusagen die ersten Buchdruckmaschinen und haben aber eigentlich nur die Bibel kopiert?
Nein, nicht die Bibel, also jede Menge anderer Sachen. Die Kirche war ja im Mittelalter der Träger der gesamten Wissenschaft. Die haben Aristoteles kopiert. Alle Bücher, die uns erhalten sind aus früherer Zeit, sind über die Klöster, die Deskriptorien und die Bibliotheken zu uns gekommen. Es gibt ja keinen Original-Handschrift von einem griechischen Philosophen mehr. Das ist ja die zehnte Generation oder zwanzigste Generation der Abschrift im Minimum.
Und beim Abschreiben entstehen natürlich auch immer wieder Fehler und in gewisser Hinsicht dann auch Neuinterpretationen, sodass diese Qualität leidet.
Diese Fehler waren eben auch mit den Ansporen von Gutenberg, einen Prozess zu erfinden, wo eben Fehler minimiert werden konnten. Weil im Prinzip bei einer Abschrift enthält jede Abschrift neue Fehler. Und ein Druck kann zwar schon fehlerhaft sein, aber da kann man dann eben hinten ein Korrekturverzeihendes dazu machen. Das wurde bei Handschriften auch bereits gemacht.
Also das war sozusagen die stille Post. Bücher kopieren war stille Post. Irgendwie, einer hat mal was geschrieben und 30 Leute haben es dann abgeschrieben. Und wenn man Glück hatte, dann stimmte das auch noch irgendwie mit dem Original überein.
Das Fernziel war ja, und das wurde auch damals, nach der Erfindung des Buchdrucks, also nicht von Gutenberg selber, aber von den direkten Leuten, die mit dem zu tun hatten, so gesehen, dass man mit dem Buchdruck wesentlich fehlerfreier Bücher herstellen konnte für ein wesentlich größeres Publikum.
Es gab ja auch noch andere Methoden der Schriftreproduktion. Waren das jetzt auch Vorlagen? Es gab ja diesen Kupferstich, also die gestochene Schrift. Was steckt dahinter?
Der Kupferstich war eben das erste große bildgebernde Druckverfahren. Im Gegensatz zum Bleisatz bei Gutenberg gab es den Kupferstich schon etwas früher. Der entwickelte sich so aus der Metallverzierung, wo der Handwerker den Harnisch verziert hatte und einen Abdruck, eine Referenz erhalten wollte und das einfach mit schwarzer Farbe oder Ros eingefärbt hat und auf Papier abgedruckt hat. Das wurde dann weiterentwickelt zum Bilderdruckverfahren. Natürlich wurden dann auch immer wieder Textelemente mitgedruckt.
Erst ging es darum, eine Vorlage zu haben, wie man stechen soll. Dann hat man irgendwann gesehen, okay, alles klar. Damit kann man ja auch drucken sozusagen. Das heißt, man hat die Bilder mit Metall gestochen, also Kupfer, weil es wahrscheinlich am weichsten war. Das war dann sozusagen die Druckvorlage. Das war dann im Prinzip aber auch schon die technische Vorlage für das, was Gutenberger gemacht hat in gewisser Hinsicht.
Nein, das Prinzip ist ganz was anderes. Wenn man auf einer Kupferplatte schreiben wollte, ein ganzes Buch, dann müsste man wie in der Handschrift Buchstabe für Buchstabe schreiben. Im Buchdruck hingegen, also in dem System Gutenbergs, hat man den Vorteil, mit vorgefertigten Metalllettern zu setzen. Da hat der Setzer eben so diesen Winkelhack und nimmt das in einem großen Setzkasten, wo die gesamten Buchstaben in mehrfacher Ausführung so oft eben benötigt werden, liegen die Buchstaben einzeln heraus und reizen aneinander zu einer Zeile. Und das ist dadurch viel schneller, als wenn man zum Beispiel in eine Kupferplatte so etwas einritzt.
Ich bezog mich jetzt eigentlich nur auf diesen Metallfarbe-Druckvorgang, der im Prinzip imitiert, aber klar...
Auch der Druckvorgang ist unterschiedlich. Also es gab ja vorher auch schon den Holzschnitt natürlich, auch für Bilder, und es wurden auch sogenannte Blockbücher vervielfältigt, wo eben eine gesamte Seite aus einem Holzstück herausgeschnitzt wurde. Eben mit dem Nachteil, dass man das dann nicht wieder zerlegen konnte und wiederverwenden konnte. Und der Druckvorgang war auf jeden Fall wesentlich schneller als im Tiefdruck. Im Tiefdruck muss man ja die Platte einfärben und die überflüssige Farbe wieder abwischen und das dann ordentlich abreiben. Und beim Buchdruck mit der Druckpresse, die auch von Gutenberg mit weiterentwickelt worden ist, konnte man das Ganze mit den Ballen einfärben und dann als Gesamtes die Seite schön abdrucken ohne Reiben.
Das heißt, da kam die Farbe sowieso nur da drauf durch die hervorstehenden Linien, nur da drauf, wo sie auch übertragen werden sollte, wie beim Stempel, während vorher waren sie in den Löchern und man muss den Rest wegwischen und es ging schneller und einfacher.
Ein großer Vorteil beim Kupferstich war, dass es viel detailgenauer war und da gibt es eben diese typischen alten Schreibschriften, die da drin vorkommen. Das kennt man aus dem aktuellen Sprachgebrauch noch, Schreiben wie gestochen. Das sind diese typischen, schönen englischen Schreibschriften. Und die wurden dann eben zuerst einmal mit der Feder geschrieben, dann im Kupferstich imitiert.
Also beschrieben auf Papier erstmal?
Geschrieben auf Papier mit Federn. Und nachdem eben diese Schriften in einer Kupferplatte wesentlich präziser und schöner geritzt werden konnten, weil das geht ja viel langsamer, das ganze Verfahren, da konnte das viel präziser gemacht werden, als es dann jemals mit der Hand wieder im Nachhinein geschrieben werden konnte. Weil mit der Hand schreibt man schneller und mit einem wesentlich, also nicht auf einer glattpolierten Metallplatte, sondern auf raubem Papier. Und auch mit der Erfindung des Stahlfeder war das dann eine große Kunstfertigkeit.
Ist das dann die Kalligraphie oder hat das noch andere Wurzeln?
Es gibt da zum Beispiel Schreibmeisterbücher. Das waren dann im Wesentlichen die Vorlagenbücher für die Schriften, wo eben festgelegt wurde, in welcher Form die Buchstaben zu schreiben waren. Und da gab es ja ganz, ganz viele verschiedene Modelle, die Buchstaben ausgesehen haben. Und die, die uns heute eben als die normalen Schriften oder das normale Alphabet oder die Form der normalen Buchstaben eben selbstverständlich erscheint, das war keineswegs von Anfang an selbstverständlich.
Das heißt, das, was man heute so als Schriftarzt kennt, das war damals sozusagen ein Vorlagenbuch, wo ein Meister einmal alle Buchstaben durchgemalt hat. Und dann musste man das nachmalen, sozusagen. Das wurde auch gemacht.
Die erste große Reform war ja da eben Kaiser Karl der Große, der dann mal eine Schriftreform eingeführt hat und eben ein Vorlagenblatt herausgegeben hat, das alle zu kopieren hatten, damit man dann wenigstens mal die Schriften lesen konnte.
Ah, eine einheitliche Schrift.
So, die erste Normung.
Unabhängig jetzt noch von Orthografie und Grammatik und anderen Problemen bei der Kommunikation, aber überhaupt erstmal, dass man sich auf bestimmte, wie heißt das, Glyphen geeinigt hat?
Glyphen wäre die Bezeichnung in OpenType heutzutage.
In digital und Typen ist dann sozusagen damals die Bezeichnung gewesen.
Ja, weil der einzelne Buchstabe war der Type.
Wo kommt denn das sprachlich her?
Wahrscheinlich aus dem Griechen.
Wahrscheinlich aus dem Griechen. Wir haben keine Ahnung. Aber so war es. Das heißt, was Gutenberg gemacht hat, ist, er hat das Drucken vor allem dadurch revolutioniert, dass er die Wörter in ihrer eigentlichen Bestandteile aufgebrochen hat, nämlich in die Buchstaben und für jeden Buchstaben eine einzelne Vorlage gemacht hat. Das heißt, man hatte dann irgendwie so einen riesigen...
Nein, Gutenberg eigentlich noch nicht. Gutenberg stellte noch 290 Formen her von den einzelnen Buchstaben, weil er eben wirklich das handgeschriebene Buch detailgenau imitieren wollte. Und damals schrieben auch schon schöne Spalten in den handgeschriebenen Manuskript. Und um diese genau imitieren zu können, brauchte er eben zum Beispiel 8 Formen von E oder eben diese ganzen Abkürzungszeichen, die es damals gab. Und insgesamt waren das 290 verschiedene Typen, die er schneiden musste.
Für ein Alphabet?
Für ein Alphabet, also für unser Alphabet.
Woran haben sich denn diese ganzen E's unterschieden?
Zum Beispiel in der Breite, also es gab einfach ein bisschen schmähleres, ein bisschen breiteres und eines, das man kombinieren konnte mit einem anderen Buchstaben, zum Verbundbuchstaben, sogenannten Ligaturen.
Die gibt es ja heute noch.
Die gibt es heute noch.
Ah, und damit sich das schöner liest?
Damit es schöner aussieht. Ob es sich schöner liest, ist leider hingestellt. Aber auf jeden Fall.
Ja, das stimmt. Manchmal ist es auch etwas verwirrend mit den Ligaturen. Ah, ein GSM-Telefon, der natürliche Feind jedes Podcasts. Ich empfehle UMTS. Das stört dann nicht mehr so sehr.
Beeinflusst das den Ton? Nein.
Zumindest die Störung, weil es eine andere Frequenz ist. Aber man muss immer noch drauf gucken und sagen, nein, ich bin nicht erreichbar. Daran hat sich eigentlich wenig geändert. Ich warte nochmal auf das Mobilfunksystem, was einem das Telefonieren dann auch noch komplett abnimmt. Dann muss man sich da halt auch nicht mehr drum kümmern. Das wäre mal eine Revolution. Aber bleiben wir bei den...
Mit drucktechnischen Mitteln nicht zu erreichen.
Nee, das stimmt. Aber bleiben wir erstmal bei dem, was mit drucktechnischen Mitteln so zu erreichen war. Okay, alles klar. Jetzt verstehe ich das erst. Gutenberg hat eigentlich jetzt das tatsächliche bildliche Kopieren des Buches, also das, was diese ganzen Abschreiber... Wie hießen die denn eigentlich, diese Leute? Schreibmönche? Schreibsklaven?
Skriptur und Skripturium.
Ja, der Skriptur sitzt im Skripturium und inskribiert. Und auch weltliche. Die durften sich dann sozusagen auch mit dem ganzen Schund den Groschenromanen der Vorzeit rumschlagen.
Abgeschrieben wurde, was bezahlt wurde, ne? Ja. Also wenn Interesse da war.
Ja, ich frage mich, was damals alles überhaupt so in Auftrag gegeben wurde, außer jetzt den Deklarationen der jeweils lokalen Fürsten.
Also die zentralen Probleme waren damals, glaube ich, noch religiöser Natur. Aber ansonsten, was da für Bücher wirklich abgeschrieben wurden, keine Ahnung.
Jetzt sieht sich unser Erkenntnis. Das heißt, okay, aber nochmal, also er hat sozusagen diesen eigentlichen Kopiervorgang automatisiert, aber dadurch hat sich natürlich dann letztlich schon dann auch dieses Schema entwickelt. Mein Gott, wozu brauche ich denn 5 ES1? Tut es doch. Das ist doch eigentlich immer das Gleiche. Aber das fehlt dann gar nicht mehr in seine Zeit, oder wie?
Bereits, also das hat sich sehr schnell in Europa verbreitet, aufgrund der Tatsache, dass er mit allen Gehilfen, die an diesem Werk der Bücher beteiligt waren, sehr bald vertrieben wurde aus Mainz. Und man darf sich ja nicht vorstellen, den Gutenberg so als ich agiere, sondern der war eben ein Unternehmer und Erfinder und Geschäftsmann. Und es ist ja bekannt, dieser Streit mit dem Herrn Fust, dem Geldgeber, der ihm eben im Gegenwert von zwei Häusern Geld geliehen hatte. Und er hat also mit mehreren Mitarbeitern dieses Projekt vorangetrieben, Bücher zu drucken. Also da ist viel Geld investiert worden, weil die auch dachten, das kommt schnell wieder raus, weil so billig abschreiben gab es vorher noch nicht. Und aufgrund dessen, dass er dann eben vertrieben wurde aus Mainz, Warum wurde er denn vertrieben? Da gab es wieder einen kleinen Streit zwischen den Landesherren.
Na, ich meine, hat er das jetzt mit seiner eigentlichen Erfindung zu tun? Sonst wie und Probleme?
Ja, so Kriege und Religion.
Jetzt habe ich dich wieder komplett aus dem Konzept gebracht. Beckwara, auf jeden Fall.
Und eben seine gesamten Gehilfen, die da mitgewirkt haben, die sind über Europa verteilt worden und haben eben in verschiedensten Ländern, wie zum Beispiel Italien in Rom, angefangen zu drucken. Und so hat sich das Wissen schnell verteilt, weil ursprünglich wollten die das natürlich alles geheim halten. Und deswegen ist es auch relativ schwierig für die Gutenberg-Forschung, weil es kaum Grundlagen gibt, also kaum schriftliche Dokumente, auch nicht handschriftliche Dokumente gibt, die genaue Fakten über das Leben Gutenbergs aussagen. Es gibt eben nur diese Prozessakten, zum Beispiel, wo sich Furst und Gutenberg dann gestritten haben, wer jetzt wen übervorteilt hat.
Berühmt ist ja immer diese Gutenberg-Bibel. War das dann auch tatsächlich das erste Buch, was er gemacht hat? Weiß man nicht, vermutet man?
Natürlich, wenn man anfängt, fängt man klein an. Das heißt, man druckt Ablassbriefe, also was damals gebraucht wurde.
Mahnung, sozusagen.
Oder kleine Grammatiken. Ne, Ablassbrief, das war also wiederum kirchlich.
Ja, kirchliche Mahnung.
Ne.
Auch nicht.
Ne, also das war dieser Ablasshandel, aus dem dann eben auch gegen den der Luther protestiert hat und die Protestanten ins Leben gerufen hat. Also man konnte seine Sünden erlassen bekommen und gegen Geld und da bekam man dann ein kleines Dokument, dass das auch so war und das war eben der Ablassbrief.
Also da wurde sozusagen bestätigt, dass man jetzt hiermit irgendwie seine Sünden ausreichend abbezahlt hat.
Mehr so eine Quittung.
Mehr so eine Quittung als eine Mahnung.
Und dann gab es eben Kramatiken.
Das ist die Zeit.
Also die Kirche bestimmt alles, ne?
Ja, klar.
Dann gab es eben Kramatiken zum Beispiel, also sogenannte Donaten. Die hat Gutenberg gedruckt, das sind also wenige Seiten und verschiedenste, solche kleine Drucksorten. Und dann wollte er aber eben, also die größte Herausforderung annehmen der damaligen Zeit, und das war der Druck einer kompletten Bibel mit mehreren tausend Seiten. Und eben in genau derselben Qualität, die damals der beste Schreiber, der beste Skriptur liefern konnte.
Und deswegen auch dieser Zwang wirklich auch alle Typen, die darin verwendet werden, dann auch so zu reproduzieren.
Deswegen der Zwang 290 Buchstaben herzustellen.
Und wie sah jetzt so die Produktion einer solchen Seite aus? Also, man hatte mal eine Seite komplett gedruckt, nehme ich an. Ja, also nicht so ein Zeile für Zeile, und dann wird irgendwie die Seite abgeschnitten, so wie beim Matrix-Drucker.
Das wäre ja irgendwie etwas sinnlos. Das Verfahren des Abdrucks ist eben eine große Seite. Also, sagen wir mal, etwa A3 wird auf einmal gedruckt. Also, das hängt dann wieder mit dem Druckvorgang und der Druckerpresse zusammen. Da muss ich eben den Anpressdruck zusammen bekommen.
Und man hat dann aber die Buchstaben so in Zeilen arrangiert, sozusagen eins neben den anderen, dran gemacht und dann festgeklemmt, oder was?
Ja, also Zeile nach Zeile gesetzt und dann das Gesamte eingespannt in einen Rahmen. Der das zusammenhielt. Und das wurde mit so einem Lederballen eintamponiert, also mit Farbe bestrichen und dann eben abgedruckt. In einer modifizierten Weintraubenpresse, also was damals am Pressen gab. Das hat der Gutenberg als Verfahrensingenieur ein bisschen modifiziert, sodass man damit besser drucken konnte.
Hatte er denn auch schon so die passende Farbschemietechnik da am Start, oder musste er das auch noch erfinden?
Es gab schon Ölfarbe, aber die hat er natürlich auch noch ein bisschen modifiziert und verbessert für seinen speziellen Zweck. Ölmalerei war auch noch eher ein neues Thema. Also es gab schon, und es ist relativ einfach vom Prinzip her, du nimmst Ros- und Leinöl und vermischst das ziemlich lange. Und das ist dann die Druckfarbe.
Ah, echt? Mehr ist das nicht.
Ja, aber das mal so hinzukriegen, dass es dann, wenn es trocken ist, nicht mehr abfärbt und dass es sich gut verreiben lässt und so weiter und so weiter und so weiter. Und man darf auch nicht vergessen, das Papier wurde ja angefeuchtet damals zum Drucken, weil es so unregelmäßig und rau war, dass das nur im feuchten Zustand wirklich die Farbe gut annahm. Ah, das auch noch. Also es musste sich ja anschmiegen an die Druckform, an die Drucklettern.
Ah, okay, verstehe. War nicht so weich.
Und eben für einen normalen Druckbogen wurde viermal gedruckt. Bei einem normalen Druckbogen, wenn er gefaltet wird, sind er vier Seiten drauf. Zwei vorne, zwei hinten. Und nachdem eben mit dieser doch noch einfachen Presse der nötige Druck nicht zusammengekommen ist und eventuell auch, wenn man die nötige Buchstabenanzahl nicht hatte, wurde eben viermal ein Bogen gedruckt, befeuchtet, getrocknet.
Das heißt, er hatte 290 verschiedene Typen, aber braucht dann natürlich auch von jedem E irgendwie viele. Und wie hat er die hergestellt? Also wie hat er diese Typen überhaupt erst produziert?
Na eben, also mit so einem kleinen Winkel, wo unten diese vertiefte Form des Buchstabens drinnen war. Das wurde dann ausgegossen mehrfach. Das waren eben Methoden des Goldschmiedes, der diese Gussverfahren kannte. Gutenberg war ja Goldschmied.
Ah, alles klar.
Und die wurden halt entsprechend oft abgegossen und dann am Schluss abgesägt damals in der Ursprungszeit. Bei den späteren Buchstaben gibt es dann diese Gusszapfen, so ähnlich wie man sie bei Plastikspritzguss-Teilen heute noch findet, wo dann eine Sollbruchstelle ist, wo der Buchstabe aufhören soll und der überflüssige Angusszapfen abgebrochen wurde. Das war noch eine eigene Beschäftigung beim Schriftguss, also das Reinigen der Buchstaben, das Fertigmachen hieß das.
Verstehe, aber die eigentliche Qualifikation, damit wahrscheinlich auch ein Großteil der eigentlichen Inspiration zur Idee kam, aus den handwerklichen Fähigkeiten mit Metall umzugehen hat. Also einfach gesehen, ich könnte doch jeden Buchstaben einzeln machen, wenn ich mir die zusammenklappe, das muss ich dann halt nur gießen. Aber das muss man natürlich dann auch erstmal können und wenn man das irgendwie gut einschätzen kann, geht es voran. Und so hat das dann geschafft. Aber dann hat sie immer eine Seite zusammengeklemmt in diesen Rahmen und dann irgendwie mit Stempelfarbe befeuchtet, dann irgendwie gedruckt. Danach war die Seite fertig und dann mussten sie alle Typen wieder rausnehmen. Das heißt Seite für Seite.
Also das ganze gründlich waschen, reinigen vor Druckfarbe wieder, das Ganze komplett auseinandernehmen und wieder zurück in diesen sogenannten Setzkasten sortieren. Also so eine große Schublade mit kleinen Unterteilungen. Das sogenannte Setzkasten, das kennt man vielleicht noch von diesen Setzkästen aus den 70er Jahren. Das war die Zeit, dass alle Bleisitzer rein aufgelöst wurden. Und das Blei größtenteils ins Altmetall ging. Und diese Schubladen, aber eben von vielen Leuten an die Wand gehängt wurden und so kleiner Nippkram reingestellt wurde. Das war die ursprünglichen Setzkästen. Und so eine Schublade mit kleinen Unterteilungen, das ist eben das, wo die Druckbuchstaben drin waren. Und da gab es eben für jeden Buchstaben ein Fach klarerweise und für häufig benötigte, wie zum Beispiel für das E im Deutschen oder in den meisten Sprachen ein größeres Fach.
Buchgrade halt.
Und natürlich auch alles sogenannte Blindmaterial, wie zum Beispiel der Lehrraum zwischen den Buchstaben oder irgendwelche Abstimmungen. Genau.
Und da gab es dann auch mehrere, ne?
Ja, also eben die Grundeinheit dieses typografischen Systems ist das sogenannte Gefiert. Gefiert ist ein altes Wort für Quadrat.
Ja.
Und das meint eben einfach dieses Klötzchen, wo der eigentliche Druckbuchstabe drauf sitzt. Und wenn dieses Klötzchen eben von oben gesehen genauso hoch ist, also der Zeilenabstand gleich ist wie die Breite, das ist dann ein Gefiert.
Das heißt, der Zeilenabstand war sozusagen auch Teil der Type.
Genau.
Der war quasi fest eingebaut.
Das ist auch wiederum eben die Punktgröße, die man auch heute noch kennt. Das ist die Höhe dieses Klötzchens. Also er hat nichts mit dem Buchstaben an sich zu tun, sondern die Punktgröße bezieht sich ausschließlich auf die Höhe dieses Klötzchens, wo der Buchstabe drauf saß.
Aber ein Punkt ist doch viel zu klein.
Ja, ein Punkt sind 0,3 irgendwas Millimeter. Das war eben so eine Einheit, die man irgendwann eingeführt hat.
Wie kam man denn da gerade drauf, auf diese Größe?
Das war erst viel später. Im 17. und 18. Jahrhundert wurden diese ganzen Sachen genauer eingeteilt. Da wurde auch der typografische Punkt erfunden, von einem französischen Buchdrucker.
Okay, wir waren bei diesem G4, dem Wide Space. Jede Type war eigentlich gleich groß, aber die Buchstaben sind ja nicht gleich groß.
Die Zeilhöhe ist natürlich bei allen gleich groß, die Breite ist nicht gleich. Die kann für jeden Buchstaben unterschiedlich sein. Natürlich ist ein I ganz schmal und ein W ganz breit.
Das war alles von vornherein auch proportional, wie man heute sagen würde. Aber dann gab es so unterschiedliche Whitespaces. Gibt es in der Typografie noch diese Geschichte mit irgendwie N-Space und M-Space?
Das sind nur die englischen Worte dafür. Das Gefiert ist auf Englisch eben der M-Space. Und das Halbgefiert, wie es auf Deutsch heißt.
Also E-M-Space heißt ein Space, was so breit ist wie ein M.
Nein, das heißt, es ist sinngemäßer Fachausdruck für das Gefiert, für ein quadratisches Stück Leeraum. Also in der Zeile ein quadratisches Stück Leeraum ist der E-M-Space.
Anschließend der Zeilenhöhe sozusagen, im Verhältnis zum Zeilenabstand. Aber wenn es so breit ist, wie die Zeilenabstand zueinander haben.
Das ist ein relativer Wert, kein absoluter Wert. Wenn die Buchstaben größer sind, dann muss das Gefiert auch größer sein. Das ist immer im Verhältnis zur Zeilenhöhe. Also Zeilenhöhe gleich die Breite, das ist das Gefiert.
Okay, das Gefiert.
Und das Halbgefiert ist eben der EN-Space. Und dann gibt es eben noch, wie man es auch in den aktuellen Layout-Programmen noch findet, das Drittelgefiert und das H-Spatium. Also der Begriff Spatium ist wieder ein ganz schmaler Whitespace, der verwendet wurde, um zum Beispiel den Blocksatz zu erzeugen oder um einzelne Wörter, die Buchstaben zu erweitern, also das vorzuheben, zu sperren, wie der Fachausdruck ist. Und das wurde eben mit so kleinen Metallstückchen, so Bleistückchen erreicht, die man hier zwischen die einzelnen Lettern hinein geschoben hat. Und das sind eben die Spazien.
Das heißt, da gab es im Setzkasten auch nochmal ein extra großes Fach für Lehrraum?
Für Lehrraum gab es dann die eigenen Kästen überhaupt. Weil da gab es ja nicht nur, was wir jetzt gerade durch besprochen haben, eben so den Whitespace in der Zeile, sondern auch den Whitespace zwischen der Zeile. Also wenn ich den Zeilenabstand erhöhen wollte, da musste ich ja eben auch ein Stückchen Metall dazwischen schieben, ein längliches, schmales. Und das waren dann Regletten und andere. Also es gab wiederum für alle das eigene Fachausdrücke.
Durchschuss ist doch auch noch so ein...
Durchschuss ist zum Beispiel auch ein sehr bekannter Begriff, genau.
Dass du diese optische Abstand zwischen zwei Zeilen und nichts richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Und Durchschuss war eben ursprünglich genau ein dünnes, längliches Blättchen, das zwischen diese ganzen Buchstabenzeilen geschoben wurde. Zwischen jede Zeile. Durchschuss. Also sie wurden durchschossen mit einem Stückchen Metall. Und das ist der Durchschuss.
Toll. Ja, so kommt man langsam mal hinter diese Begriffe. Das heißt, so eine einzelne Seite zu produzieren, war für Herrn Gutenberg schon noch eine Menge Arbeit. Also bis er irgendwie mal so eine Seite Bibel gedruckt hat, da ist echt Zeit vergangen. Das heißt, und wie viele Seiten hat er dann gemacht? Also ich meine, hat er dann gleich mehrere Kopien angefertigt?
Ich denke, es waren, glaube ich, ungefähr 200 oder so.
200, das heißt, nachdem er eine Seite gesetzt hat, Wurde die 200 mal abgedruckt. Ah, okay, gut, also nicht jetzt irgendwie, ich mache jetzt mal eine Bibel, sondern ich mache gleich mal 200 Bibeln.
Das wäre ja sonst sinnlos, ne? Na klar, er wollte es wahrscheinlich verkaufen. Für eine einzelne wäre man ja mit Schreiben schneller. Aber für 100, wenn man mit Schreiben bei weitem nicht mehr schneller. Das ist der große Vorteil des Trucks. Also wenn man eine hohe Auflage hat, dann ist die bei weitem billiger.
Und Bibeln wird man natürlich immer los, also um 1400. Ja, aber bestimmt total die Bibelknappheit.
Das war für den Kleros auch interessant, weil man konnte eben garantieren, dass diese Ausgabe 200 mal gleich war.
Dass überall die gleichen Regeln standen.
Kein Druckfehler. Beziehungsweise dann gab es eben das Druckfehlerverzeichnis am Ende des Buches. Und der Buchdruck war eben bestimmend für alle diese Normierungen, die wir heute an einem Buch als selbstverständlich ansehen. Also angefangen mit der Seitennummerierung, die in einer Handschrift nicht selbstverständlich war. Angefangen überhaupt, dass das Buch einen Titel hat und dass ein Autor genannt wird. Das Impressum. Das Impressum hängt natürlich auch wieder zusammen mit Zensur, klarerweise.
Ja, weil das war ja im Prinzip auch ein bisschen die Geburtsstunde des Copyright, wenn ich das richtig erinnere.
Ja, das Copyright war ja zu dieser Zeit immer noch sehr kurz beschränkt. Also das waren so im Zeitraum von 5 bis 15 Jahren. Genauso wie das Patentrecht.
Wie meinst du das jetzt? Also 15 Jahre lang durfte man es nicht nachdrucken? Nachdrucken. Echt? Damit ging es gleich los? So zeitliche Beschränkung?
Das war das Privileg, das sogenannte, diese frühen Vorläufer des Patentrechts, die laufen unter dieser Bezeichnung das Privileg.
Ah, ich hatte das noch als Erinnerung, dass auch nicht jeder sozusagen die Erlaubnis dann bekam, Dinge zu kopieren. Weil es ja sozusagen, ich meine, klar, man konnte da eine Menge Bibeln damit machen, aber man konnte jetzt auch beliebige Pamphlete und, ja, was weiß ich, religionsfeindliches Zeug eben, das habe ich fast gesagt, ins Internet stellen, in die Öffentlichkeit geben. Und das war natürlich gefährlich, so wie heute irgendwie böse Webseiten.
Und deswegen wurde ja der Buchdruck eine wesentliche Voraussetzung für den Protestantismus, der sonst eben eine Gegenbewegung von vielen geblieben wäre. Aber die waren genau zur richtigen Zeit, am richtigen Ort und haben eben gedruckt und alle ihre Thesen nicht nur an die Tür der Schlosskirche genagelt, sondern auch gedruckt und über die deutschen Lande verbreitet.
Das heißt, der Luther war dann sozusagen so ein richtig finniger Technik-Freak?
Mitarbeiter von ihm. Also die waren sich sehr wohl bewusst, dass die Öffentlichkeit natürlich zu tun hat mit gedruckten Worten, dass man die besser erreicht, als mit handgeschriebenen Briefen.
Das heißt, deine Thesen, die er da irgendwie an die Kirchentür rangebabbert hat, das war auch gedruckt?
Die waren wahrscheinlich noch handgeschrieben, aber wurden natürlich dann verteilt.
Interessant. Und wie ging es dann weiter? Also du hast ja schon gesagt, Gutenberg wurde dann vertrieben und mit ihm seine ganzen Assistenten und dann breitete sich die ganze Drucktechnik wie ein Lauffeuer über Europa aus. Und alle waren am Drucken.
Ja, kann man so sagen.
Und dann passierte 500 Jahre lang nichts und es wurde eigentlich die Technik immer nur etwas verbessert, bis die nächste Revolution kam.
Die Technik wurde grundlegend eigentlich kaum verbessert. Und zwar das Papier wurde relativ bald verbessert. Ich glaube, die erste Automation war die Papierherstellung. Die zweite Verbesserung war die Druckmaschine, die praktisch beinahe unverändert bis 1800 bestanden hat noch. Und dann, also um 1800 wurden die ersten Druckerpressen komplett aus Metall gebaut.
Aus was waren die denn vorher gebaut?
Aus Holz.
Ach echt? Ach so jetzt das Gerüst und so weiter.
Das gesamte Ding ausschließlich aus Holz. Inklusive Schrauben, die waren auch aus Holz. Du kennst vielleicht so alte Holzschrauben und Verbindungsstücke. Und dann wurden eben sukzessive schon einzelne Teile, also zum Beispiel diese Spindel. Das ist ja auch so ein Schraubgewinde, die wurde dann schon aus Metall gefertigt. Aber die erste Presse, die dann wirklich aus massiven und vollständig aus Metall war, die war um 1800.
Ach so und das waren dann sozusagen auch die Maschinen, die dann diesen eigentlichen Andruck, die diese Andruckkraft dann auch entsprechend verbessern konnten.
Da konnte man dann eben größere Formate drucken.
Ich habe mich eben schon gewundert, weil du meintest, da kommt nicht genug Power rüber, da kommt doch ordentlich was runter. Aber es ist halt alles natürlich weich, wenn das irgendwie ausreicht.
Das ist ein Entwicklungsprozess. Aber man braucht ja eben auch nicht ganz so viel Andruck, bei gefeuchtetem Papier, da kommt noch ein Filz drauf. So viel Zeit hatte man dann schon noch.
Das heißt, über die Zeit war es eigentlich Prozessverbesserung, das Papier wurde besser, die Maschinen wurden stabiler gebaut, man erfand neue Mechaniken, um jetzt den eigentlichen Satz vielleicht zu verbessern.
Kaum. Vom Grundprinzip her eben alles unverändert.
Das heißt, der Setzer saß jetzt über Jahrhunderte immer noch irgendwie mit seiner Pinsette vor seinem Setzkasten und hat irgendwie die Dinge da eingeweitet.
Schon mit den Fingern. Also vielleicht für ganz kleine Schriftarten.
Für 3 Punkte. Fürs Kleingedruckte sozusagen. Das wird es ja damals auch schon gegeben haben. Ich weiß nicht, wie klein konnte er denn drucken? Wie fein war denn so dieser Typ? Wie muss man sich denn das vorstellen?
Gutenbergschriften waren noch nicht so klein, weil das war ja eben die Imitation der Handschrift zu seiner Zeit. Und da war die Zeilenhöhe um die 7 Millimeter. Aber eben im Fortschreiten des Buchdrucks wurden die Buchstaben dann immer kleiner, weil man eben in Metall, die natürlich wesentlich kleiner herstellen konnte und nachher gießen konnte, also man mit der Hand schreiben konnte. Und das entwickelt sich so langsam weiter. Also es wird immer kleiner. Und auch die Papierformate wurden ja, also nicht die Papierformate, sondern die Buchformate wurden kleiner und die Druckbogen wurden größer. Und man konnte also immer mehr, immer schneller Bücher produzieren.
Bücher waren am Anfang so richtige Klötzer, so richtig so fette Schinken. Kann man ja mal aus dem Film, mit viel Staub, so wie man es eben aus der Begrifflichkeit noch kennt.
Am Anfang waren alles Folianten. Also Folio bezeichnet eben das einmal gefaltete Blatt Papier. Und das ist doch noch so ein relativ großes Format.
Und dann kam irgendwann die eigentliche Bindetechnik, dass die Dinger dann so zusammen genäht wurden, oder wie?
Das war von Anfang an. Das war ja schon auch bei den Handschriften vorher. Die Buchbinderverarbeitung hat sich ja in dem Sinn nicht verändert durch den Buchdruck. Aber man hat dann eben angefangen, kleinere Buchformate herzustellen. Was war das zum Beispiel für ein Privier? Da gibt es eben diese Bogenteilungen, wenn immer kleiner. Oktaf ist vielleicht noch ein Begriff, das Oktaf-Format.
Oktaf-Heft? Oh ja, so etwas hatte ich in der Schule. Stimmt, das ist so A5-artig.
Genau, und das ist eben der Achtelbogen. Und CDs ist dann der Sechzehntelbogen.
Das hat aber jetzt mit den DIN-A-Größen, die wir heute kennen, nichts zu tun, oder?
Genau, DIN-A4 ist 1922. Also überhaupt die DIN gibt es glaube ich so 1918 oder so. Also die Gründung der deutschen Industrienorm, die es ursprünglich ist. Und diese Formate, die ich angesprochen habe, also eben Folio, Quad und so weiter, die beziehen sich auf die Teilung, also wie oft ein Bogen gefaltet wird. Und das ist im Prinzip ein relativer Wert. Da geht es nur eben darum, wie oft der Bogen gefaltet wird. Und wie groß der Bogen vorher ist, ist unbestimmt im Wesentlichen.
Das ist aber bei den DIN-Normen jetzt ja auch nicht anders. An Null falte ich irgendwie zusammen, und dann bin ich irgendwann bei A, was auch immer.
Ja, aber eben man ist bei einem bestimmten Format und bei einer bestimmten Proportion. Und die bleibt auch so. Und also eben jede Halbierung von einem DIN-Bogen geht eine Nummer runter. Ich fange da an bei A0, gehe auf A1, A2, A3, A4 und so weiter. Und das ist jeweils eben die Hälfte.
Aber Quadrat und Optat folgen im Prinzip demselben?
Ja, aber nicht derselben Proportion. Wenn man nämlich ein längliches Stück Papier hat und das zum Beispiel einmal faltet, dann hat man ungefähr ein quadratisches Format. Und wenn man das wieder faltet, hat man wieder längliches. Und das war bei den alten Bogenformaten so. Also die waren nicht in dieser 1 zu 1,42 Normierung wie das DIN-Format. Und das ist der große Vorteil des DIN-Formats, dass diese Proportion, die mit jeder Halbierung gleich bleibt, da gibt es natürlich nur eine. Und die ist auch dann aufgenommen worden in die DIN-Norm. Und deswegen haben eben die alten Buchformate auch teilweise ein bisschen höher und teilweise ein bisschen länglichere. Und so unterscheiden sich die Buchformate ein bisschen. Also das sind so Sachen, die man heute vielleicht in der Bibliothek am ehesten findet. Weil da sind diese traditionellen Buchformate noch aus Bezeichnungen gängig.
Bücher haben ja eigentlich auch heute noch immer noch eine extreme Bandbreite an Format. Das ist dann sozusagen auch dieser Vergangenheit verschuldet.
Ja, natürlich. Alles ist der Vergangenheit geschuldet. Aber das wird natürlich nach wie vor dann trotzdem aus dem DIN-Bogen rausgeschnitten und der Rest fällt halt weg und geht zurück in die Papierfabrik und wird Recyclingpapier oder Papier.
Es gibt ja auch diesen Begriff Bleisatz. Bezeichnet das jetzt genau diese Gutenberg-Idee?
Das bezeichnet prinzipiell genau diese Idee.
Hat der dann auch schon Blei verwendet von Anfang an? Weil das am schwersten war?
Nein, weil das am einfachsten zu gewinnen war, glaube ich. Das war das häufigste Metall damals. Wir spielen mehrere technische Faktoren zusammen in der Auswahl des Materials. Gutenberg hat nicht reines Blei verwendet, weil das wäre zu weich. Aber Blei hat den Vorteil, dass es sich gut gießen lässt. Das kennt man vielleicht noch vom Bleigießen zu Silvester. Bleizinn und Antimon waren die Mischung mit dem größten Anteil Blei. Der große Vorteil der Kombination dieser drei war das eine Härtet. Alle drei zusammen haben einen niedrigeren Schmelzpunkt als jedes der einzelnen Metalle. Aber genau diese Mischung, die Gutenberg gefunden hat, war bis 1950, 1960, 1970, also bis zum Ende des Bleisatzes, also schon modifiziert, aber im Wesentlichen unverändert verwendet. Die erste größere Veränderung des Satzsystems war eben erst kurz vor 1900 die Einführung der Zeilen-Gusssysteme. Das bekannteste ist die Linotype. Und das kann man sich so vorstellen wie eine überdimensionierte Schreibmaschine. Und da liegen eben die einzelnen Matrizen für jeden Buchstaben oben in so Kanälen drinnen. Und auf Tastendruck fällt eine herunter. Auf einen Sammelriemen wird so gesammelt zu einer gesamten Zeile. Und wenn diese Zeile voll ist mit diesen kleinen Messing-Matrizen-Stückchen, dann werden die Keile, die dazwischen stecken, also statt dem WideSpace, dem EM, kommen hier so Doppelkeile hinein. Und diese Keile wurden dann zusammengedrückt und nach oben geschoben, dann wurden sie breiter, um eben den Blocksatz zu machen. Also das war der große Vorteil von diesem System.
Das habe ich jetzt noch nicht so ganz verstanden. Also was war jetzt Sinn und Zweck dieser Systeme? Du hast gesagt, Zeilen Guss. Also was wird denn da gegossen?
Die Bleibuchstaben, die eben vorher im Handsatz, so einzeln aus dem Setzkasten zusammengesucht wurden, wurden dann so on demand sozusagen, wurden dann so live gegossen, als Gesamtes. Also eine Zeile auf einmal, Linotype, also one line of types.
Das heißt, man hatte sozusagen jeden Buchstaben als Vorlage nur ein einziges Mal und in dem Moment, wo die Zeile gesetzt wurde?
Du musst es denn so oft haben, wie in einer Zeile vorkommt, klarerweise. Das E kann ja wiederum sehr oft vorkommen. Also du brauchst schon von jedem mehrere Vorlagen und die werden insgesamt zu einer Zeile formiert. Und im Blocksatz war im Handsatz grob ein Drittel der Zeit des Satzes wurde auf die Herstellung des Blocksatzes verwendet. Und das machte diese Maschine eben einfach durch einen Doppelkeil. Also wenn du dir vorstellst, du hast einen Keil und einen zweiten Keil, also der Keil ist eben unten dicker und du hast einen zweiten Keil, der ist oben dicker und die beiden stehen so zusammen und du schiebst die auseinander und zusammen und dadurch wird dieses insgesamt sich ergebene, die parallelen Seiten werden dicker und dünner.
Ja, also einfach so zwei Dreiecke ineinander schiebt, dann wird es halt irgendwie breiter, umso mehr man sie ineinander reinschiebt.
Und das ist eben der Doppelkeil.
Ach, damit wurde dann sozusagen die Ausrichtung der Worte gemacht. Das war jetzt das eigentliche Ziel.
Das war der variable Leerraum. Das war das erste Mal, mechanisch, da gab es einen variablen Wide Space.
War das jetzt die Kernmotivation zur Herstellung dieser Maschine?
Die Kernmotivation war Geschwindigkeitssteigerung. Da gab es ja schon industrielle Revolution, da gab es dann auch schon Rotationspressen. Also alles war schneller, schneller, schneller.
Also Rotationen, wo dann sozusagen die Vorlage auf so einem Blech war?
Nein, das ist der Offset-Druck, das ist wieder was anderes.
Ach so, okay, ich bringe alles zueinander. Aber wo sich im Prinzip immer im Kreis gedreht hat, dass man eine Seite nach der anderen drucken konnte.
Im Bleisatz war ja normalerweise das Ding klarerweise flach, wenn das einzelne Teil besteht. Und es gab die Stereotypie, das ist vielleicht als Begriff besser im Gedächtnis.
Stereotypie?
Das Stereotyp, das war eben ein technisches Verfahren aus dem Buchdruck. Da wurde Papmache auf dieses gesamte Blei draufgetan, also so Bogen. Und das wurde dann abgeprägt. Und in diese Papmache, man glaubt es kaum, konnte man eben die Seite nochmal nachgießen. Und das ist die sogenannte Stereotypie.
Da kommt dieser Begriff her?
Ja, da kommt dieser Begriff her. Und da konnte man eben ein Duplikat eines Bleischtoxen machen.
Also Stereo im Sinne von, dass man zwei hatte sozusagen?
Genau.
Die Vorlage und die Einwahl?
Ja, die man duplizieren konnte. Das Interessante daran für den Druck von hohen Auflagen war eben, dass man diese Pappe vorher rund biegen konnte und dann rund ausgießen und dann eben eine Hochdruckform hatte für den Rotationsdruck.
Ah, verstehe, alles klar. Und dadurch konnte man dann sozusagen schneller drucken.
Und das Langsamste in dem gesamten Ablauf wurde eben immer mehr und mehr der Setzer. Also das war ja im Buchdruck immer schon so, dass ungefähr drei bis sechs Setzer später einen Buchdrucker belieferten, weil das Setzen eben im Verhältnis so viel länger dauerte als das Drucken. Aber je schneller die Maschinen wurden, das Setzen wurde ja nicht schneller. Also man brauchte immer mehr und mehr Setzer, um diese Maschinen beschäftigt zu halten.
Oder man brauchte Schnellsetzer. Jungs, die richtig pfiffig und flink mit den Händen waren, sozusagen.
Ja, da brauchte man ein gutes Manuskript erst mal.
Voll der Stress.
Und um eben den Satz zu beschleunigen, gab es diese Idee, wir setzen mit einer Maschine.
Ah, und das ist dann sozusagen die Linotype gewesen.
Und das ist eben so ein Ding wie eine Schreibmaschine, also du hast eine Tastatur, die auch wiederum nicht die Standard-Schreibmaschinen-Tastatur-Belegung hat, die wir heute kennen, sondern alle diese Bleisatzsysteme hatten eigene Tastaturbelegungen.
Weil die auch sehr viel mehr Zeichen brauchten.
Die hatten natürlich eben das G4 drauf und diese ganzen Extra-Tasten und die hatten die auch eher so angeordnet, wie man sie brauchte.
Aber es gab nur noch ein E, nicht mehr fünf.
Genau, aber beim Gießen gab es trotzdem noch die Matrizen in entsprechenden Anzahlen.
Okay, jetzt habe ich es auch verstanden. Also Buchdruck als solcher wurde irgendwie immer schneller, die Sätze wurden das Problem. Und jetzt wollte man schneller setzen und dann wurde auch dafür sozusagen eine Satzmaschine gebaut. Und jetzt hatte man quasi das erste Mal auch wirklich eine Tastatur. War das dann auch die Geburtsstunde der Tastatur?
Nein, die Schreibmaschine wurde...
Die gab es schon vorher?
Die gab es, also die original Remington, also Scholl's Clitten, die erste Schreibmaschine, die industriell hergestellt wurde, war 1876. Und die Linotype war, glaube ich, 1896. Aber die ersten Patente für Schreibmaschinen gab es schon ab 1820. Und im gesamten 19. Jahrhundert gab es mehr als 200 Patente für Setzmaschinen, die alle praxisuntauglich waren. Und die erste, die dann wirklich gut funktionierte, das war eben die Linotype. Also das hängt mit vielen Faktoren zusammen. Auch Maschinenbau, also das ist eine Präzisionsmaschine, die hat tausende von Teilen, die müssen zusammenpassen. Also warum das jetzt genau erst so spät gelungen ist, das hat vielschichtige Gründe. Aber jedenfalls um die Jahrhundertwende war das Teil da und wurde eben gebaut bis 1976. Was man gar nicht glaubt.
Krass, 76.
Ab 1950 wurde ja bereits der Hochdruck weitgehend und immer mehr abgelöst durch den Offset-Druck. Der Offset-Druck ist das mit den dünnen Alu-Platten.
Den besprechen wir gleich nochmal, aber bleiben wir nochmal kurz bei der Maschine, weil das fasziniert mich gerade total. Also diese Linotype hatte einfach eine Tastatur und es ging jetzt darum, dass man mit der Tastatur quasi die Satzbuchstaben aneinander reilt, dass man die nicht mehr aus dem Setzkästchen rausholen muss. Das heißt, ich drücke jetzt auf das A und dann fällt oben aus dem Fach, aus dem A-Fach, fällt so ein A runter?
Fällt so eine Gießform für ein A, also eine negative Form für ein A fällt da runter.
Das heißt, ich habe die ganze Negative, okay, das heißt jetzt verstehe ich auch, warum ich mehrere Es brauche, klar. Also die fallen alle so rein und ich kann die Abstände, ich kann ja auch noch Variablen mit diesen Dreiecken machen. Das heißt, ich habe so zwei Dreiecke, die ich so presse.
Von oben hin kommen und den Variablen in den Weißraum ergeben.
Und hat er diesen Blocksatz dann auch automatisch gemacht oder muss man den schon von Hand machen?
Nee, also das schickte man die Zeile zum Gießen und das wurde in einem Arbeitszug eben, wurden die Keile zusammen gedrückt, sodass die Zeile...
Achso, dann ist es automatisch gleichmäßig, weil, aha, das ist ja knifflig, putzig. Okay, und dann aber im Prinzip, wie bei dieser Stereotypie, wurde das sozusagen nochmal abgegossen. Aber dann eben auch wieder in eine Pappmache?
Nein, aus Zeile, also aus Bleizeile.
Achso, da wurde eine ganze Bleizeile sozusagen erzeugt.
Diese Zeile war ja viel schneller als immer im Handsatz. Und wenn man wirklich das gesamte Ding nochmal brauchte, konnte man ja immer noch eine Stereotypie von der gesamten Seite machen.
Das heißt, man hat sozusagen dann, was vorher Buchstabe für Buchstabe war, hat man jetzt Zeile für Zeile produziert.
Es gab auch für das Einzel-Gießen von Buchstaben.
Und gab es da irgendwie große Ausschränkungen? Man kann das ja auch alles so schnell wieder, das Blei kann man auch schnell wieder einschmelzen. Das heißt, da war dann auch so ein permanentes Recycling dieser Zeilen möglich. War das nicht scheiße giftig alles? Die Leute nicht irgendwie?
Nein, die Dämpfe sind giftig. Aber an und für sich Blei, man darf es sich halt nicht...
Ich habe mir gerade Gedanken gemacht über die Setzerfluktuation.
Bleivergiftigung war schon eine Berufskrankheit von Setzern. Aber die waren eigentlich aus reiner Blödheit. Wenn man das Blei mit den Händen bleisetzt, muss man sich nachher nicht das Wurstbrot mit der selben Hand zum Munde nehmen.
Oder mal ein A-Futtern oder so.
Oder beim Bläsen des Manuskriptes, den Fingerbefeuchten vorm Umblättern oder so. Das wäre natürlich nicht so gut. Aber grundsätzlich ist Blei nur durch Hautkontakt giftig. Die Dämpfe an und für sich sind, glaube ich, nicht giftig. Was ich mich so erinnern kann.
Chemikassen wäre er nicht. Aber vielleicht noch mal ein anderes Chaos Radio Express, irgendwann später mal zu produzieren über die Giftigkeit von Dämpfen. Das heißt, die Linotype war eigentlich die erste wirklich nennenswerte Revolution des Setzens.
Und es gab eben auch die Monotype und den Typograph und ungefähr zehn andere Systeme, die wichtig waren.
Die alle ähnlich funktionierten?
Ja, also die Monotype setzte eben, kost nach einem automatisierten Prinzip, Einzelbuchstaben in Blei. Und das war auch das erste Ding von diesen Ganzen, das Lochband gesteuert war. Das heißt, es hatte einen guten Ansatz. Die Monotype und Linotype sind fast zeitgleich entstanden. Und hier wurde getrennt bei der Monotype in einen Tastapparat und in einen Gießapparat. Also am Tastapparat, das ist wirklich so, kann man sich vorstellen wie eine Schreibmaschine, da hast du eben das Lochband hergestellt. Und das zweite Teil war dann die Gießmaschine. Und da hast du eben das Lochband hineingegeben. Und das kost dir so Zeile für Zeile und Buchstaben für Buchstaben diesen Text, den du vorher da getippt hattest. Und hatte eben den Vorteil, also beim Standard-Pleisatz hattest du immer das Problem, wenn du das Buch nochmal drucken wolltest, musstest du den gesamten Satz aufheben. Das war dann der sogenannte Stehsatz. Und da gab es in jeder Druckerei einen großen Keller mit Tonnen von Seiten. Und da war die Erfindung der Stereotypie natürlich schon ein weiter Schritt nach vorne, weil dann hat man nur diese abgeprägten Papiermartern aufgehoben. Und bei der Monotype war dann der Vorteil, wenn das Band einmal fehlerfrei gelocht war, dann musstest du eben nur mit dieses Lochband aufheben. Und dann hattest du da deinen perfekten Stehsatz. Den konntest du dann jederzeit wieder nachgießen und nachdrucken.
Voll automatisiert sozusagen. So wie die Lochkarten für die Computer, hatte man im Prinzip ja dasselbe Prinzip. Und wie war das dann codiert?
Das war eine Codierung durchaus wie ASCII, könnte man sagen. Also die Codierung, die hier verwendet wurde, ist zwar nicht ganz dasselbe wie bei diesen frühen Telegraphensystemen, aber es sind gleichbare Prinzipien. Also es sind so wie die Bodo-Telegraphensysteme. Die hatten ja auch so Lochstreifen. Und die wurden zum Teil auch später verwendet für fortgeschrittene Pleisatsysteme dann. Da hatte man dann eben die Idee, man könnte ja diese getippten Texte vorher mit dem Telegraphen übertragen, für Zeitungen zum Beispiel. Und die können dann alle landesweit denselben Text drucken. Und das geht dann eben besonders gut, wenn man dasselbe Lochband für den Telegraphen, also das ja schon gab für den Telegraphen, wenn man genau dieses System auch für die Satzmaschine verwendet.
Das heißt, erst war der Telegraph da und dann wurde sozusagen beschlossen, dass man dieselbe Codierung nimmt dafür?
Ja, also für die Linotype wurde dann eben so ein Zusatzsystem gebaut, dass sie genauso funktionierte wie die Monotype, dass du eben das Ding mit Lochstreifen steuern konntest. Und es war der sogenannte TeleType Setter, den gab es dann so ab 1930, wurde aber erst richtig wichtig, ungefähr ab 1950. Und wiederum nicht zur Übertragung der Texte, sondern zur Steigerung der Geschwindigkeit.
Das ist dann sozusagen... Das heißt, es ging jetzt auch wirklich... Der TeleType war gar kein... Also war kein... Also ich meine, es ist ja sozusagen die Geburtstunde des Fernschreibers.
Nee, Fernschreiber gab es schon. Also, das sind parallele Systeme.
Aber der Fern...
Das ist ja nicht wie heute im Computer, wo alles immer mehr zusammenwächst und in den Kästchen stattfindet, sondern damals waren es alles, alles, alles getrennte Systeme.
Ja, aber ich dachte, der Fernschreiber, der erste wäre schon der Teletype gewesen. Oder ist Teletype jetzt die Bezeichnung für dieses Satzsystem gewesen?
Teletype Setter. Das ist eben ein Kunstwort aus Teletype. Das ist der Fernschreiber auf Englisch.
Und Type Setter. Ah, okay. Teletype Setter. Alles klar.
Die Gießmaschine auf Englisch. Und Teletype Setter, das war das Kunstwort für das Zusammenführen dieser beiden Systeme.
Das heißt, man konnte dann so richtig schön, schon digital Informationen übermitteln und die wurden dann auch noch gleich gesetzt. Und wofür kam das primär zum Einsatz?
Zur Geschwindigkeitssteigerung der Systeme. Also wiederum, es wurde wenig übertragen, sondern es wurde nur, es gab immer mehr Taster, also immer mehr Leute, die nur geschrieben haben. Und da konnten eben zwei, drei Leute wiederum so viel schreiben, dass diese Maschine immer was zu gießen hatte.
Ah, das alte Problem, dass die Setzer nicht schnell genug waren, war jetzt sozusagen auch, dass man nicht schnell genug tippen konnte, irgendwie damit das Ding, ah.
Und da natürlich auch Fehler machte.
Taster, hast du gesagt.
Taster, ja. Wie hießen die so, die Leute? Taster hießen eigentlich die Geräte, aber das waren so die Keyboard Operators, würden wir heute sagen, oder in der frühen Computertechnik.
Typisten.
Also die Schreibstube.
Ja, ich meine, das hat ja dann auch die Qualität des, ja, der Sekretär, würde ich jetzt nicht sagen, aber der Schreibmaschinen-Schreiber-Typisten bestimmt. So, umso schneller sie schreiben konnten, umso besser. Die Schreibmaschine, hast du ja gesagt, hat sich schon parallel dazu entwickelt, oder davor eigentlich schon. Ist das von Anfang an auch schon das gewesen, was wir so als Schreibmaschine heute so kennen, mit diesem runden Typen-Anordnung?
Also das erste Modell war durchaus nicht unähnlich, ja. Also eben wurde von der Firma Remington hergestellt, die gerade ein kleines Loch in der Kasse hatte, weil der Bürgerkrieg aus war und der Waffenverkauf ein bisschen schleppernd wurde. Und so haben die angefangen, eben Nähmaschinen herzustellen und eben auch die ersten Schreibmaschinen. Es gab schon vorher Schreibmaschinen und es gab auch Kleinserien von hunderten von Stück. Aber Remington war der erste, der das wirklich, also in dieser Fabrik wurde, die wirklich industriell produziert. Und das war unter anderem die Geburtsstunde der heutigen Tastatur. Deswegen ist es vielleicht doch interessant, sich das ein bisschen näher anzuschauen. Das war nämlich so, die ersten Schreibmaschinen hatten Unteranschlag. Das kann man sich heute nicht richtig vorstellen. Das heißt, du hast einen einfachen Hebel und wenn du die Taste drückst, schlägt die Type von unten gegen die Walze. Am Anfang sogar noch mit Kohlepapier. Da gab es noch nicht mal diese übliche Rolle.
Das Band mit der Farbe?
Das Farbband. Und diese...
Die Type schlug von unten gegen die Walze.
Also wirklich mit dem Hebel. Ja, mit dem Hebel. Und da ist eine Walze. Du drückst so und das Ding schnittelt nach oben. Also das den Hebel schlägt.
Also er haut nicht von vorne dagegen, sondern von unten. Okay, aber halt so auf die Walze drauf. Und das Papier war eingeschaltet.
Du konntest auch nicht sehen, was du gerade tippst. Das ist ja auch viel später dann.
Ah, verstehe. Das war jetzt sozusagen der erste mechanische Ansatz.
Das war der erste Ansatz. Und damit sich die eben nicht so oft verhackten, hat der Bruder von dem Patentanwalt Densmoor die statistische englische Buchstabenverteilung, also die Häufigkeit, in welcher Buchstabe nach welchem anderen Buchstaben kommt, und hat die möglichst verteilt über die Tastatur.
Damit man zwei Buchstaben, die häufig zusammengedrückt werden, weit auseinander liegen und sich die nicht verhacken.
Das war in Zeiten, wo man an zweihändig schreiben nicht gedacht hat. Man hätte auch nicht gedacht, dass man damit jemals schneller schreiben könnte, als mit der Hand. Das sind ganz andere Voraussetzungen damals. Es ging nur darum, dass sie das nicht verhackten. Falls doch mal wer ganz schnell mit dem Zwei-Finger-Prinzip zwei Buchstaben hintereinander anschlug, dann hätten sie sich verklemmt. Insgesamt wäre das eben langsamer gewesen, weil du hättest das erst entwirren müssen.
Aber tatsächlich ist das ja auch für das Zwei-Hände-Schreiben gar nicht so doof, weil die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass man links und rechts bedient, recht hoch ist.
Und es gab damals, wie gesagt, Remington war der erste, der das wirklich im großen Stil hergestellt hat. Und deswegen hat sich die Tastatur auch durchgesetzt. Aber es gab damals hunderte andere Schreibmaschinenhersteller. Und praktisch jeder von denen hatte ursprünglich eine eigene Tastatur. Und da kommt wieder die Normierung zum Tragen. Es ist jetzt nicht so wichtig, ob sich das bestes System durchsetzt. Sondern es geht primär darum, dass es überhaupt ein System gibt, das sich durchsetzt.
Da ist das erste eigentlich immer ganz weit vorne.
Und da war das erste und das größte, wurde genommen, wie in vielen Fällen vergleichbar.
Wow, das heißt, war dann diese Typen an Stäben, was eine Schreibmaschine im Wesentlichen ausmacht, die waren dann auch schon in diesem Rondell ausgerichtet?
Bei diesem ersten Modell nicht, aber das hat sich dann relativ schnell weiterentwickelt. Dieses Modell, was du da meinst, das ist die Wagner Typewriter. Das sind dann Patente, also eher schon um 1900 herum. Das ist wieder mal ein Auswanderer aus Deutschland, der das dort entwickelt hat. Und da geht es eben um einen indirekten Anschlag, den man in Worten jetzt schwer beschreiben kann. Aber es ist eben nicht mehr ein einfaches Stäbchen, sondern es ist schon ein System von mehreren Einzelteilen, die sich zusammen bewegen und den Anschlag erzielen und deswegen auch von vorne gegen die Walze schlagen können, obwohl du ja eigentlich nach unten drückst.
Einfach so eine Hebelumlenkung, dass es nach vorne klackert.
Genau, und das ist dann eben ein bisschen später, als es da der Wagner Typewriter war. Also die Schreibmaschine entwickelt sich dann eben so weiter, wie wir sie vielleicht heute noch in Erinnerung haben.
Und auch komplett separat eine von diesen Set-Systemen?
Komplett separat. Also das waren Bürosysteme. Also ganz lustig, wenn man sich eben diese erste Remington ansieht, da war man sich noch nicht ganz sicher, ob das jetzt im Office-Bereich benutzt werde oder eben so privat. Und nachdem das eben derselbe Ingenieur war, der die Nähmaschinenfabrik vorher eingerichtet hatte, und war das so ein schwarzes Ding mit Blumen verziert, auf so einem Tischchen, und mit unten diesen Fußpedal für die Zeilenschaltung, so wie man es von diesen alten Handnähmaschinen kennt. Schaut genau gleich aus. Also es ist auch relativ kurios. Es gab es aber wirklich nur in den ersten paar 100 Modellen. Da gab es eben die Zeilenschaltung mit dem Fußpedal. Aber grundsätzlich entwickelt sich die Schreibmaschine eben völlig unabhängig.
Tolle Idee eigentlich. Man hat auch schon mal überlegt, ob ich nicht vielleicht mal einen Fußpedal für meinen Computer gebrauchen könnte, um irgendwie so die ein oder andere Bedienvorgang abzunehmen, den ich sonst mit der Hand oder mit der Maus machen würde. Aber ich habe jetzt ehrlich gesagt keinen guten Vorschlag welche. Aber so, allein mal so Return drücken irgendwie, einfach nur noch mit dem Fuß. Vielleicht, vielleicht ist das ja was.
Return gibt es ja nicht mehr.
Return gibt es nicht mehr?
Also das Sinn der Zeilenschaltung bei der Schreibmaschine war ja eben in die nächste Zeile zu kommen. Und wenn man heute am Computer schreibt, es gibt keine nächste Zeile, das macht ja das Programm automatisch, den Umbruch der Zeile.
Ja, naja.
Also und Return ist eigentlich heute im Computersatz der Absatz.
Das stimmt.
Aber eben, nächste Zeile zeichnen gibt es nicht mehr.
Textverarbeitung macht, ja. Ja, Carriage Return, ich meine, insofern ganz interessant auch nochmal, also Teletype, da bin ich schon ein bisschen wach geworden. Es gibt ja viele solche Tasten, die ja so Funktionstasten waren im Kontext eben dieses Setzens oder des Direktschreibens, die dann später ja auch in die Datenkommunikation übernommen wurden. Also Return ist jetzt das beste Beispiel, also Carriage Return ist es ja eigentlich, also Wagenrücklauf, da steckt ja wirklich dann auch so dieses, ich habe so einen Druckwagen, der so mitmarschiert irgendwie, der fährt dann wieder nach vorne, bzw. bei der Schreibmaschine war es ja eigentlich eher die Walze, die zur anderen Seite ging. Genau, also der Wagen hat sich nicht bewegt, aber die Erde unter ihr sozusagen. Es gibt ja noch so andere. Shift hat sich da ja eigentlich auch schon so, dieses Shift war ja wirklich auch so ein mechanisches Heben.
Das mechanische Heben des Korbes, ja. Also zuerst des Wagens und später des Korbes.
Sodass man irgendwie auf diesen Typen unten die kleinen Buchstaben hatte und oben die Großbuchstaben. Und wenn man halt die ganze Walze gehoben hat, das weiß ja heute kein Mensch mehr. Wer hat denn noch eine Schreibmaschine?
Ich hatte ja so einen Teil noch.
Deswegen heißt es auch Shift. Man schifftet wirklich so. Man hebt das irgendwie alles hoch. Was gab es denn noch? Caps Lock gab es bestimmt nicht. Aber der Tabulator ist ja auch schon in den Schreibmaschinen eingeführt worden.
Das ist eher von den Rechenmaschinen, aber nachdem die ja eng miteinander befreundet waren, der richtige Nachfolger auf der Tastatur ist ja der Ziffernblock. Das ist eigentlich die Rechenmaschine. Wenn es nicht ein Laptop ist, sondern eine richtige Tastatur, dann hat man die Schreibmaschine und daneben die Rechenmaschine, sozusagen den Ziffernblock. Die Tabulator-Taste war eben für Tabellen, der Tabellensteller, hieß das auf deutschen Schreibmaschinen. Also um eben Zahlenkolonnen schön untereinander stellen zu können, hattest du den Tabulator. Und das war bei den Schreibmaschinen, so wie ich sie noch gekannt habe, also als kleiner Junge, da hattest du so ein kleines Metallstück, das du so eingestellt über die Breite des Papiers. Und dort, wo die eben waren, da blieb dann der Schlitten hängen, wenn du die Tabulator-Taste gedrückt hast. Und dann gab es noch diese lustige 1000er und 10.000er und einer Taste. Und die veranlasste wiederum, den Schlitten mit drei Tasten wieder zurückzuhüpfen. Um eben, also wenn du eine 1000er-Stelle hattest, um das zu tippen, also gab es eigene Tasten. Es gab einen Haufen eigener Tasten, die es nicht mehr gibt.
Eine 1000er-Taste habe ich hier nicht. Was hat die gemacht, die 1000er-Taste? Das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Drei Stellen zurück hüpfen.
Warum denn?
Wenn du 1000er- und 100er- und 10er-Beträge untereinander schreibst, dann gehst du zuerst zum Tabulator und hüpfst dann drei Stellen, zwei Stellen oder eine Stelle zurück.
Alles klar, verstehe. Rechtsbündig sozusagen. Okay.
Aber eben viele Funktionsbezeichnungen aus dem Fernschreiber und aus den Telegrafencodes sind über den Umweg von diesen ganzen Großrechnern auch im ASCII-Code am Computer gelandet. Also diese bekannten ersten 32, glaube ich, sind Steuerzeichen.
Kontrollcodes, genau. Ja, da gibt es eine Menge.
Und das Wichtigste ist ja, dass es Bell war. Bell war die Glocke beim Fernschreiber, wenn die Zeile aus war.
Nummer 9. Ding, genau. Du bist zu weit drüber gekommen. Das konnte man aber auch übertragen, also war dann eben das Bell-Zeichen.
Das gibt es auch in manchen Programmen, macht das tatsächlich ein Bing.
Was mir gerade noch einfällt, also mit der Schreibmaschine, die Schreibmaschine war dann im Prinzip auch die Geburt von Schriftarten mit gleicher Laufweite. Vorher der ganze Satz war ja, wie wir schon mehrfach erwähnt haben, alles sehr proportional. Und jetzt gab es halt diese Mono-Space-Fronts, wie sagt man das eigentlich auf Deutsch?
Nicht-proportional.
Nicht-proportionale Schrift, okay.
Im Normalfall spricht man von Diktensystemen im Schriftsatz. Also die Dikte ist eben der alte Schriftgießer-Fachausdruck für die Breite des Buchstabens. Und die ersten Schreibmaschinen waren natürlich eben von gleicher Dikte. Also jeder Buchstabe gleich breit.
Alles in diesem selben Gefährt sozusagen.
Das ist meistens eher ein Halbgefährt. Das ist übrigens ein guter Punkt noch. Es gibt die Tabellenziffern, die kennt man heute auch noch. Und Ziffern waren im traditionellen Pleisatz immer ein Halbgefährt breit. Was ist das? Damit man eben eine Tabelle untereinander, also damit man schön Ziffern untereinander stellen kann. Und eine steht immer über der anderen. Deswegen waren die Ziffern im Pleisatz immer gleich breit. Und das war ein Halbgefährt. Also ein EN-Space auf englisch. Das ist ein Punkt, der eben in OpenType korrigiert worden ist. Da kann man eben auswählen, ob man Tabellenziffern will oder unterschiedlich Breite für den normalen Text. Weil die Eins ist natürlich schmeler als alle anderen.
In dem Buchdruck sieht das dann doof aus.
Die hat dann immer so ein hübsches Loch. Aber in der Schreibmaschine waren sowieso auch die Buchstaben alle gleich breit. Die haben sich aber auch weiterentwickelt. Da gibt es auch Systeme für den Bürosatz, die dann dicke Systeme entwickelt haben.
Es gab ja später noch einen weiteren technischen Schritt bei der Schreibmaschine, diese Kugelkopfschreibmaschinen. Die kamen relativ spät. War das nicht auch erst so eine 60er-Jahre-Erfindung?
Schätze ich mal, also 50er, 60er.
Ist das eigentlich heutzutage die angesagte Technik? Ich weiß nicht, werden überhaupt noch Schreibmaschinen verkauft?
Ich glaube, die, die noch hergestellt werden, sind schon eher diese Daisy-Wheel-Schreibmaschinen.
Von Typenrad.
Das ist ja auch eins der ältesten Systeme. Also die Hammond und Blickensterfer und die ganzen alten Systeme. Also einige der ersten Systeme hatten auch Sammeltypenträger, wie die Überbezeichnung lautet. Das war eben insofern interessant, weil man da die Schriftart austauschen konnte. Oder eine Kursive nehmen. Das war ja auch der große Punkt bei der Kugelkopfschreibmaschine. Aber diese Differenzierung in den dicken Systemen gibt es schon wesentlich vorher. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, aber ich glaube, die Hammond oder eine dieser frühen Systeme hatte das auch schon eingebaut.
Dass man unterschiedliche Frontbreiten wählen konnte, oder wie?
Die ersten Systeme, die es gab, hatten einfach drei Breiten. Das bedeutet, das I ist schmal, das O ist mittel und das W ist breit. Das ist zwar jetzt noch nicht der richtige Schriftatz, man sieht den Unterschied sofort, aber es ist besser, als wenn alle Buchstöcke eben konstante Breite haben. Diese Systeme gibt es mit Varityper und Multigraph, also verschiedenste Büroartikelhersteller, die das eingeführt haben.
Die also schon eine Schreibmaschine brauchten, aber die zumindest halbwegs hübsch lesbare Sachen haben wollten, wo es jetzt irgendwie nicht so richtig wäre.
Eine Schreibmaschine hatte ja schon jeder. Um dann wieder neue Modelle zu verkaufen, muss man sich was einfallen lassen. Und dann gibt es eben die Weiterentwicklung der Schreibmaschinen. Aber das Interessante an diesen Systemen mit mehreren Dichten ist eben das, dass die dann für den frühen Offset-Druck als billiges Satzsystem verwendet wurden.
Ja, vielleicht mal wieder zurück von den Schreibmaschinen hin zu dem eigentlichen Satzsystem, die ja dann irgendwann so in die digitale Ära überging. Aber bevor das passierte, gab es ja dann noch eine andere, neue technische Entwicklung, den Fotosatz. Was wurde da gemacht? Irgendwann hatte man sozusagen keinen Bock mehr, Blei zu gießen und für jede Zeitung da Silvester zu spielen?
Das ist ein komplexes Zusammenspiel von verschiedenen Technologien. Es gibt ja das Drucksystem und es gibt das Satzsystem. Und die kurz vor 1800 erfundene Lithographie, der Steindruck, der hat das selbe Prinzip, wie der heute verwendete Offset-Druck auch noch hat. Also man hat einen porösen Stein, der wird mit Fettkreide oder Fetttusche oder was immer beschrieben, mit irgendwas Fettigem. Und der Rest des Steines ist wasserempfänglich. Und auf dieser Abstoßung von Fett und Wasser beruht das Druckverfahren. Also es wird immer das Ganze gefeuchtet und mit Druckfarbe einmal drüber gewinnt. Und dann wird es mit Papier eben abgedruckt.
Und das, was schleimig ist, das hält die Farbe nicht. Und das, was porös ist, hält die Farbe.
Also chemisches Druckverfahren. Abstoßung von Fett und Wasser.
Und so funktioniert auch der Offset-Druck.
Genau. Und der Offset-Druck hat seinen Namen dadurch, dass nicht wie bei der Lithographie und bei allen bisherigen Druckverfahren, das Papier direkt auf dem Druckträger abgedruckt wurde, sondern der Offset-Druck hat seinen Namen davon, dass eben über eine Gummivalze gedruckt wird. Abgesetzt.
Das heißt?
Es ist kein direktes Druckverfahren.
Das heißt, die Vorlage ist so eine Metallplatte?
Das ist eine Aluminiumplatte, die rund aufgespannt ist. Auf dieser Aluminium bzw. viele Metallplatten haben dieselben Eigenschaften wie so ein Lithos-Stein. Also die frühesten Versuche waren mit Zink. Da gibt es den Zinkdruck. Blechdruck ist kein eigenes Verfahren, weil das auch oft davor kommt. Blechdruck meint das Bedrucken von Blech wie für Blechdosen oder Blechspielzeug. Und das sind auch die Ursprünge des Offset-Drucks, weil man eben Blech direkt schwer bedrucken kann als Material. Und da wurde dann eben gern der Lithos-Stein abgedruckt auf eine Gummimatte und diese Gummimatte übertragen auf das Blech. Das ist der Blechdruck.
Das heißt, es kommt schon Farbe auf das Blech?
Das Blech ist das Papier, deswegen heißt es Blechdruck. Das war jetzt noch der Zwischenschritt. Und beim Offset-Druck direkt übernimmt das Aluminium die Funktion des Lithografiesteins. Das ist immer schwer zu verstehen.
Aber was ist jetzt das Synonym zum Fett auftragen auf diesen Stein?
Die Druckfarbe ist fettig. Druckfarbe ist fetteiltig. Leinöl war es früher. Heute sind es Erdöl-Derivate. Aber auf jeden Fall ist die Druckfarbe der Fettsteil.
Ich dachte, es wird da Fett drauf gemacht, wo die Farbe nicht hängen bleiben soll.
Das war bei der Lithographie so. Beim offset ist es anders. Beim manuellen Druckfang wird das von dem Computer belichtet. Mit einem Laserdrucker auf die Alu-Platte geschrieben. Da ist eine organische Beschichtung drauf.
Wenn der Lichtstrahl auftrifft, was passiert dann?
Dann bleibt die oben. Die nicht belichtete Schicht kommt eben runter.
Also wird etwas abgetragen?
Prinzipiell ist das wie ein Laserdrucker. Nur eben, dass der nicht auf Papier druckt und dann elektrostatisch mit Toner das Bild entwickelt wird. Sondern eben, dass eine Beschichtung drauf ist, die dann als Druckträger dient. Das war jetzt keine richtig gute Beschreibung.
Laserdrucker funktioniert ja auch. Beim Laserdrucker wird ja die Walze quasi magnetisiert, sodass die den Toner mit aufnimmt, oder?
Der Laserdrucker basiert auf dem elektrophotografischen Kopierverfahren, also Xerox kurz gesagt. Und die Xero-Kopie funktioniert so. Also es gibt eine lichtempfindliche Walze, die wird elektrostatisch aufgeladen. Und wo immer diese Walze belichtet wird, also beim Kopiervorgang, bricht diese Ladung zu Start zusammen, also fällt weg. Und die übrigbleibende Ladung auf dieser Walze wird mit entgegengesetzt geladetem schwarzen Pulver praktisch entwickelt.
Das heißt, man strahlt mit dem Laser dahin, wo man keinen Toner haben will. Das Weiß wird sozusagen aufgetragen.
Aber vom Prinzip her ist es auch elektrostatische Aufladung von kleinsten Rußpartikeln, die kunststoffumantelt sind. Und beim Fixieren wird durch diese Heißwalze... Dann wird das sozusagen abgedrückt auf das Papier und durch Hitze eingebrannt? Und durch Hitze eingebrannt.
Und beim Offset-Druck ist es jetzt inwiefern ähnlich, inwiefern anders?
Der Offset-Druck, die Belichtung erfolgt vom Prinzip her mit dem Laser, wie in einem Laserdrucker auch. Und das Prinzip des Offset-Drucks an sich ist das Prinzip der Lithographie, also des Steindrucks. Und beruht eben auf der Abstoßung von Fett und Wasser. Also von Druckfarbe und Wasser.
Das heißt, diese Aluminiumplatte, die jetzt auf dieser Rolle ist, die dreht sich und dann?
Und wird gleichzeitig immer mit Farbwalzen benetzt und mit Forchtwalzen benetzt. Also das Feuchtmittel enthält nicht nur Wasser, das sind auch Alkohol und alles Mögliche drinnen. Aber es wird jedenfalls gleichzeitig immer mit Wasser und mit Farbe versorgt. Und das hält sich in einem stabilen Gleichgewicht, sodass eben die farbführenden Stellen kein Wasser annehmen und die nicht druckenden Stellen eben keine Farbe annehmen.
Dann wird das aber auf eine Gummivalze übertragen.
Von dieser Gummivalze auf das Papier übertragen.
Und warum überträgt man es nicht direkt aus Papier?
Diese Übertragung über die Gummivalze hat große Vorteile verschiedenster Natur. Also erstens kann der Bedruckträger rauer sein. Also das Papier kann schlechter sein. Weil die Gummivalze kleine Unebenheiten wieder ausgleichen kann.
Also es würde auch ohne Gummivalze funktionieren, aber der Prozess an sich funktioniert besser mit schneller.
Man kann schneller fahren.
Ja, und wie sind wir denn jetzt gerade drauf gekommen? Eigentlich wollten wir ja zum Fotosatz kommen.
Der Offset-Druck ist eben eine wichtige Voraussetzung für den Fotosatz. Weil wenn du eben im Play-Satz Buchstaben setzt und du willst im Endeffekt mit einer Offset-Druckplatte drucken, was macht das für einen Sinn, wenn du einen Play-Satz davon vorher machst, sondern du willst ein System, wo du gleich direkt einen Druckfilm herkriegst. Am Anfang wurde das eben tatsächlich so gemacht, es wurde auf der Linotype gesetzt, dieser Play-Satz einmal schön sauber abgedruckt auf eine Zellopferanfolie sozusagen und das dann also in der Offsetmaschine gedruckt, weil die Geräte eben alle schon da waren, aber im Endeffekt vom Produktionsprozess ist das ja widersinnig. Und da kommen eben die Fotosatzmaschinen hinein.
Das heißt, die dann wie ein Laserdrucker auf so eine Walze direkt das draufgelenkt haben?
Also das ist das letzte Stadium eben, der heutige Stand der Technik.
Aber angefangen hat es anders.
Die ersten Fotosatzsysteme funktionieren so wie ein Fotonegativ eigentlich. Also du hast den Buchstaben in Negativ auf einem Filmträger. Und der wird belichtet auf einen zweiten Film, der dann im Endeffekt die Seite wird. Also der eigentliche Satz.
Also Fotosatz wird dich im besten Sinne, gar nicht mal nur, weil es jetzt visuell abgeht, sondern wird dich auch so wie eine Fotoentwicklung abläuft.
Wie ein traditionelles Foto mit einem Negativ.
Das heißt, die Typografie als solche, also die Schriftarten, Schriftsätze, wie auch immer, liegen dann sozusagen im Film vor.
Was vorher eben Matrizen waren, die ausgegossen wurden und die Buchstaben wurden, ist hier eben ein fotografisches Negativ, wodurch belichtet wird.
Und waren das dann jetzt auch schon, wann kamen denn diese ersten Fotosätze?
Wiederum, die ersten Systeme sind vor 1900. Und in Amerika, ungefähr 1950, wurden die kommerziell tatsächlich eingesetzt, weil auch der Offset-Druck noch nicht ganz so gut war. Also wie die Lithographie war der Offset-Druck am Anfang hauptsächlich für das Bild vorgesehen. Also bildgebendes Verfahren. Das hängt aber eben beim Offset-Druck auch damit zusammen, dass es eben noch kein vernünftiges Set-System gab. Also man kann sich die Entwicklung nicht denken. Man muss sich immer anschauen, die Druckgeneration und die Satzgeneration und eventuell sogar noch die Papierherstellung. Weil das ein Gesamtprozess ist, wo dann hinten das Buch rauskommt.
Das heißt, dieser Fotosatz, die Idee gab es früh, aber so richtig die begleitende Technik, um das viabel zu machen, kam eigentlich erst mit der Zeit.
Die ersten Systeme, die auch gebaut wurden, waren 1920, 1930. Aber der Punkt, um den es wirklich ging, war der Mengensatz, also ein gesamtes Buch hier zu setzen. Und da gibt es genau von den Firmen Linotype und Monotype und den ganzen anderen großen, die da waren, gab es die ersten Systeme, die dann eben Mengensatztauglich waren. Und die waren in der ersten Generation einfach umgebaute Bläsatzmaschinen, wo anstelle einer Gies-Einrichtung, wie zuvor, eben praktisch so eine fotografische Einrichtung war, wo dann die einzelnen Buchstaben eben auf Film belichtet wurden. Und das hat sich dann weiterentwickelt. Und die nächste große Stufe bei den Fotosatzbelichtern waren dann eben die Lichtsatzmaschinen. Also nicht mal der Fotosatz, sondern der Lichtsatz. Im Fotosatz gibt es eben ein fotografisches Negativ des Buchstabs, das sichtbar ist. Und beim Lichtsatz wird mit Kathodenstrahlröhren, also sinngemäß kleiner Fernseher, wird der Buchstabe aus Linien bzw. Punkten ausgebaut. Also gleichzeitig die Geburtsstunde des heutigen Bitmaps am Computer kommt dort her. Und auch die Ansteuerung wurde eben übernommen aus diesen Systemen wie beim Tele-Typesetter. Also das waren dann schon programmierbare Rechner eigentlich. Also spezielle Systeme, vielleicht mal eine Workstation. Also die konnten dann nur Buchstaben in Punkte zerlegen und diese auf Film wiedergeben. Das aber sehr sehr schnell. Und der Vorteil, warum das gemacht wurde, war wiederum die Suche nach der Geschwindigkeit. Also das musste schneller gehen als bisher.
Das war die Geburtsstunde der Bitmap. Das heißt, die eigentlichen Glyphen, die Schriftzeichen, wurden tatsächlich in so einer Matrix definiert.
Wie quadriert das Papier oder Millimeterpapier?
Mit was für einer Auflösung?
Mit ungefähr 500 Linien pro Millimeter am Anfang.
500 Linien pro Millimeter? Jetzt muss ich das mal in dpi umsetzen. Hohe Auflösung auf jeden Fall. Weil, ich meine, in der Typografie, im Schrift, Es sind ungefähr 1200 dpi.
Was ist das in Millimeter?
1200 dpi in Millimeter, nahe ein, oh Gott, das muss man mal rechnen.
Also 500 pro Zentimeter, ne?
Also 1 Inch sind 2,54 Zentimeter. Also 254 Millimeter. Und wenn ich jetzt, oh Gott, alle hören zu, während wir uns jetzt hier verrechnen.
Also ich gucke mal nach.
Ja, guck mal nach. Ich rechne mal. Also wir haben irgendwie, was hast du gesagt? 500 Zeilen, das ist auch immer die Eier. Also man redet ja gar nicht von Dots, sondern man redet immer von Lines. Und wenn ich höre CRT, ist natürlich kein Wunder, weil auch Fernsehen hat sich ja eigentlich immer in Linien definiert. So, und das heißt, wenn ich irgendwie 500 Zeilen pro Millimeter.
Das müssten pro Zentimeter sein.
Pro Zentimeter, ja, das meine ich doch. Worum muss ich das jetzt rechnen? Pro Zentimeter?
Wie viel sind das? 1200 durch 2,54.
1200 dpi sind das?
Also nur, wenn man mal auf die entsprechende Zentimeteranzug kommt.
472.
Ja, eben. Also das sind nicht 500.
Also das, was ein guter Laserdrucker heutzutage macht.
Genau. Das war die ursprüngliche Auflösung eben von den professionellen Foto-Satzgeräten. Weil die ersten Laserdrucker hatten ja 300 dpi.
Genau. Da war das noch beyond und total high-tech. Da war von 1200 dpi noch nicht so richtig zu träumen.
Also Zentimeter.
Das heißt, jetzt bekam man sozusagen auch das Problem langsam, dass jetzt die eigentlichen Fonds, wie sagt man? Sagt man Fond? Sagt man Schriftart? Schriftatz? Schriftstil?
Fond war ursprünglich eben der Guss. Also dafür gibt es auch deutsche Fachausdrücke, nur es sind eben mit der ganzen Computerei die englischen Fachausdrücke aus dem Bleisatz in den Computer gerührt.
In der deutschen Weißung? Kannst du gerne einwerfen.
Und Fond oder Found ist eben eine Schriftgröße ursprünglich. Also Found ist der Guss. Type Foundry ist der englische Ausdruck für Schriftgießerei.
Und heutzutage für eine kleine Glitche, die selber Fonds macht. Verstehe. Ja, aber schön zu sehen, wie das so im Zusammenhang steht. Und jetzt so etwas wie so eine Schriftart, wie sagt man das? Schriftart, Font-Face?
Typeface, also das Schriftgesicht.
Und wie viele Schriftgesichter haben sich denn so entwickelt? Ich meine, am Anfang, gut, da gab es diese Schreibmeister-Hefte, das hatten wir ja schon mit so unterschiedlichen Schriftstilen. Dann hat man sich aber eigentlich eher auf weniger als mehr geeinigt. Aber mit dem Buchdruck über die ganzen Jahre hinweg wurde ja sozusagen die Reproduzierbarkeit immer besser, sodass man eben ganz andere Typefaces auch verwenden konnte. Und wann hat das so eingesetzt, dass das so eine eigene Kultur wurde, da ein eigenes Typeface zu entwickeln? Also von Anfang an, oder kam das irgendwie erst in den letzten Jahren?
Natürlich, also in den Schreibmeisterbüchern gibt es das seit 1500 in den Gedruckten, die mit Holzschnitten schon gedruckt wurden. Und da wurden einfach aus Spaß und Freude Zierschriften entwickelt. Die wurden aber selten für den Buchdruck adaptiert. Das heißt, die grundsätzlich für den Mengentext verwendeten Schriften waren also sehr reduziertes Repertoire. Und in der Lithographie wurden dann ab 1800 bis 1900, wo die Lithographie dann vom Offsetdruck abgelöst wurde. Da konnte man eben auf dem Stein zeichnen und schreiben und frei jede beliebige Form anbringen. Und sehr beliebt in der Lithographie war eben auch die Imitation des Kupferstiches, wo also ganz feine verzierte Striche und Linien, wie eben in der Schreibschrift oder auch irgendwelche beliebigen Formen mit vielen verzierten Schnörkeln rundherum üblich waren. Und die konnten in der Lithographie gedruckt werden. Und jetzt war es dann so, dass eben alle kleinen Drucksorten, wie Briefpapier, Rechnungen und so weiter, wurden eben dann im Steindruck erzeugt. Und der Buchdruck war eben nur mehr für den Text zuständig, weil eben Sachen mit viel Text zu drucken, das konnte die Lithographie als einziges nicht so gut und nicht so billig, wie der Buchdruck. Und erst im Rahmen dieser Entwicklung kommen dann eben auch im Schriftguss eben Headlineschriften, also verzierte Schriften, wie wir sie heute eigentlich gewohnt sind im Allgemeinen. Also diese größere Schriftvielfalt entsteht erst kurz vor 1900 eigentlich. Und der Schriftentwerfer in einem heutigen Sinne, die ersten Schriften, die nicht in einer Schriftgießerei entworfen wurden und wo wir noch die Namen kennen, die sind auch erst kurz vor 1900, wo also das Gewerbe sich nochmal spezialisiert und eben der Beruf des Schriftentwerfers entsteht. Also in einem heutigen Sinne.
Schriftentwerfer. Und ja, aber so mit diesen Fotosatzmaschinen spätestens war das ja dann aber auch schon richtig so ein Business, auch neue Schrift, also Typefaces zu verkaufen.
Aber als erstes waren die einfach mal sehr zufrieden, wenn die ganzen Mengen, Textsysteme, also wenn die alten Schriften, wenn die funktioniert haben und wenn die alten Schriften alle da waren, um eben bestehende Aufträge fortführen zu können, zum Beispiel. Und für die ganzen Überschriften, also für die Größe oder Plakate oder überall, wo man Schriften in größeren Größen gebraucht hat, da gab es eigentlich wieder eigene Systeme. Die sind dann später im Computer zusammengewachsen. Aber ursprünglich waren das eigene Geräte, wie zum Beispiel die TierType oder LetterFoot. Also LetterFoot war ein Gerät, das wiederum aussieht wie ein normaler Fotovergrößerer. Nur, dass man oben statt eines Fotonegatives einen Streifen hat mit Buchstaben, die man dann eben auf Fotopapier belichten konnte. Und natürlich wurden diese ganzen Maschinen immer weiterentwickelt und das konnten dann irgendwann alle Aufgaben halbwegs damit erledigt werden. Aber das waren unterschiedliche Systeme. Und eben für diese Headlineschriften, für die großen Plakatschriften, gab es immer unterschiedliche Schriften. Die wurden ja auch in der traditionellen Druckerei entweder von den Lithografen mit der Hand gezeichnet oder im Buchdruck waren das Holzbuchstaben. Das waren auch teils eigene Firmen, die diese großen Schriften in Holz hergestellt haben und nicht die Schriftgießereien, die die Bleischriften gemacht haben. Das waren unter Umständen auch getrennte Firmen und auch andere Druckereien.
Aber jetzt mit dem Lichtsatz dürfte ja dann spätestens schon die Zeit angekommen sein, wo sozusagen auch aus den Vollen gegriffen wurde, wo also wirklich viele Schriften sich entwickelt haben, viele alte Schriften dann auch digitalisiert wurden. Im Prinzip reden wir ja jetzt hier von der Digitalisierung. Also noch beim Fotosatz ist das irgendwie alles analog?
Beim Fotosatz ist alles analog, klarerweise, weil es ist ein fotografisches Negativ, durch das belichtet wird. Und beim Lichtsatz wird es klarerweise mehr und mehr digital. Also die ersten Geräte sind wahrscheinlich noch mit Röhren ausgestattet. Aber die erste Gerätegeneration ist von Rudolf Hell, ich glaube Digi-Set, und der ist von 1965 auf jeden Fall. Und in dem Gerät sind bereits alle Schriften in Punkte zerlegt. Also die wurden eben mit einem Photomultipler gescannt. Also einen CCD-Chip gab es ja noch nicht, das war ein Photomultipler. So wie den alten Trommelscannen. Und da wurden die Buchstaben gescannt und dann eben direkt konnten verwendet werden in diesem Gerät. Und mit einer eben fantastischen Geschwindigkeit werden damals die Verhältnisse von einer Million Zeichen pro Minute gesetzt werden. Also nicht, dass ich jetzt wieder eine falsche Zeileinheit verwende.
Eine Million?
Aber auf jeden Fall, also Geschwindigkeiten, die weit über das hinaus gingen, was man damals sonst mechanisch machen konnte im Bleiguss.
Spätestens jetzt ist der Beruf des Setzers komplett ausgestorben. Das ist jetzt sozusagen nur noch der Operator der Maschine.
Der Setzer ist nach wie vor vorhanden, nur die Tätigkeit hat sich gewandelt.
Ja, doch stimmt, es gab ja noch, in den 18er Jahren, da konnte man sich auch zu sowas noch ausbilden lassen, glaube ich sogar. Da gab es noch diesen Ausbildungsberuf des Schriftsetzers.
Das war eben zu der Zeit, bevor der PC so richtig da war und PostScript und Test- und Publishing so richtig da waren.
Jetzt geraten wir langsam mal in die digitale Zeit. Das ist jetzt sozusagen der nächste Bruch. Bis hierhin war das alles noch eine relativ konsequente Weiterentwicklung der Urtechnik sozusagen, vom Goldschmied.
Der erste Bruch war schon mit Fotosatz-Offset-Druck. Weil man von Blei wegkam. Und zwar auf beiden Ebenen. Sowohl im Satz, kompletter Bruch, als auch im Druck, kompletter Bruch.
Mit dem Offset-Druck.
Hier gibt es dann das erste digitale Schriften-System. Das war das Icarus-System von der URW-GCBH. Und das ist eben bereits von 1975.
Icarus, das war eine Software?
Das war Hardware-Software, also ein gesamtes System. Also ich glaube nicht, dass es speziell Hardware war, aber es waren sicher adaptierte Dinge zu der Zeit. Und da konnte man eben mit so einem Folienplotter von digitalen Daten die Buchstaben schneiden. Also in rote Maskierfolie, wie man das vielleicht auch vom Siebdruck kennt. Und mittels eben so einem Folienplotter angesteuert durch dieses Icarus-System konnte man Buchstaben schneiden. Und das war ursprünglich also konzipiert, um die Vorlagen für den Fotosatz noch herzustellen. Dann ist man draufgekommen, wenn man den Buchschirm schon punktweise als Vektor digitalisiert hat in diesem System, kann man auch Pixel oder Pitmaps daraus berechnen, direkt ohne irgendwelche Umwege über so einen Scanner.
Und für den Lichtsatz verwenden.
Und für den Lichtsatz verwenden. Und in weiterer Folge ist man dann draufgekommen, dass man diese Vektor-Informationen, die man ja eh schon hat, auch dann verwenden kann, für zum Beispiel Postscript-Schriften. Also, dass man das relativ einfach alles Bestehende wieder weiterverwenden konnte in der übernächsten Technologie. Also geplant für Fotosatz, verwendet zum Einsatz der Lichtsatz und später noch ein bisschen fortgeführt.
Das heißt, dieses Icaro-System war jetzt eigentlich das erste System, was eigentlich abgekommen ist von, okay, also zuerst war ja alles sozusagen noch handgeschnitzt, handgemalt.
Also es gibt industrielle Systeme zur Herstellung, den maschinellen Stempelschnitt oder Stempelfräsen. Das gab es schon auch 1885, gibt es die Stempelfräsmaschine. Also ab da konnte man schon maschinelle Sachen herstellen und das markiert auch den Punkt, wo Schriften zum ersten Mal also industriell produziert wurden. Also da gab es nicht einen einzelnen Stempelschneider, der so eine Schrift machte oder 20 nebeneinander, die die Schrift machten, sondern da wurde das weiter aufgetrennt. Also es gab den Zeichensaal, die erstellten Vorlagen in etwa A4 Größe mit Großbuchstabenhöhen von vielleicht 15 cm. Also hier wurde der Buchstabe aufgezeichnet. Nach diesen Buchstaben wurde eben mit einem Pantographen eine Schablone gefräst, hergestellt. Und nach dieser Schablone in einem dritten Schritt die Mata oder der Stempel gefräst, also der negative oder der positive erhabene Buchstabe gefräst.
Pantograph, das ist dieser Zirkel-ähnliche mechanische Doppelstift, mit dem man halt aus einer kleinen Zeichnung die größere machen kann durch eine direkte mechanische Übersetzung.
Pantograph entwickelt sich aus einem Reduktionszirkel. Also wenn man sich einen Zirkel vorstellt, wo der Win-X aussieht, wo die Beine in beide Richtungen gehen, und man stellt ihn auf einen bestimmten Maßstab auf, dann kann man eben auf der einen Seite abheben, also die Größe abheben und auf der anderen Seite wieder auftragen. Und das hat man einen fixen Vergrößerungsmaßstab. Und wenn man diesen Zirkel in die Waagrechte bringt und verdoppelt sozusagen, dann hat man so einen Scherengitter, und drei in einer Linie liegende Punkte verhalten sich immer proportional gleich. Das ist wieder so ein mathematisches Prinzip. Und einer dieser Punkte wird fixiert. Der nächste Punkt ist der Zeichenpunkt. Und der dritte Punkt ist der Füllstift, der sogenannte. Und mit diesem Füllstift wird die originale Zeichnung nachgefahren. Und der mittlere, der Zeichenstift, reproduziert die im Normalfall in einem kleineren Maßstab.
So eine Art Abpausen, aber ohne dass man was durchscheinen lassen muss. Und man kann auch gleich noch den Maßstab dabei beeinflussen. Das heißt, so wurden dann sozusagen die Schriften von der Originalzeichnung abgenommen, aber jetzt kommen wir ja...
Fräst, ne?
Und gefräst.
Also man konnte ja dann statt diesem Bleistift eben auch einen Fräser einspannen.
Okay, aber diese ganzen Systeme waren einfach noch voll auf Handarbeit basiert und auf Mechanik. Und vor allem gab es ja in dem Sinne keine mathematische Beschreibung, wie ein...
Also eigentlich ist für mich der wesentliche Bruch schon vor dieser maschinellen Stempelfräsen. Also weil man braucht eben, um diese Stempelfräsen zu machen, eine gezeichnete Vorlage. Und auf der gezeichneten Vorlage ist die Kontur ausschlaggebend. Das heißt, früher war der Buchstabe sozusagen ein flächiges Ding, das abgedruckt worden ist, dann ist das hier das erste Mal, dass die Kontur den Buchstaben bestimmt.
Also mit hier meinst du jetzt das Icaro-System?
Nein, den maschinellen Stempelschnitt, also mit dem Fräsen. Das ist mit den Pantographen dieses Ding.
Ah, okay, gut, der das an der Kante sozusagen ausschneidet.
Diese Zeichnungen hatte man dann eben ab 1900, bereits hergestellt für die Linotype. Also das wäre nicht möglich gewesen, die Linotype herzustellen, weil für die Linotype brauchte man über 1000 solcher kleinen Matrizen. Und es wäre nicht möglich gewesen, die mit den älteren Verfahren herzustellen. Das war noch eine wichtige Voraussetzung, dieses Stempelfräsesystem, um überhaupt die Linotype funktionsfähig zu bekommen. Und da hatte man eben jetzt solche Zeichnungen, wo ein Buchstabe mit ungefähr 15 cm Höhe drauf war, in einer dünnen Linie, Pleistiftlinie oder anderes umrandelt. Und das war die eigentliche Definition der Schrift, wie sie dann eben von diesen Maschinen gefräst wurde. Diese Zeichnungen konnten dann, nachdem sie schon vorhanden waren, nachdem das ohnehin die selbe Firma Monotype war, die vorher eben die Bleigießmaschine erzeugt hat und dann die Fotosatzmaschine, dann konnten die eben abfotografiert werden oder eben mit dem Icarus-System digitalisiert und eben in diese Maskierfolie geschnitten werden.
Also was macht jetzt dieses Icarus-System?
Also das besteht natürlich aus einem Engabe-Gerät. Also man hat einen Digitizer-Sensor, kann man sich vorstellen wie eine Maus mit einem Koordinatenkreuz drinnen. Und man hat diese Zeichnung, geht mit der Maus drüber und klickt nacheinander die einzelnen Punkte an. Also zuerst kommt eben der Ursprungspunkt. Das heißt, das ist praktisch der linkeste Rand vom Buchstaben.
Das A links unten.
Der Ursprung des Koordinatensystems muss angegeben werden. Und anschließend jeder Punkt durchgeklickt. Und es gibt natürlich...
Was heißt jeder Punkt? Ich meine, das sind ja keine Punkte, sondern ja Linien.
Eben. Also wir kennen ja... Und es ist selbst relativ selbstverständlich, in Bézier-Kurven zu denken bereits, wenn man Entwürfe im Kopf anstellt. Und die haben damals die Regel gemacht, alle 30 Grad ein Punkt. Also bei Rundungen und auf jeden Fall bei Übergängen von Geraden in Kurven und die üblichen Sachen, die sieht man ja. Aber eben bei gekrümmten Linien, auf jeden Fall alle 30 Grad einen Punkt.
Weil so eine Krümmung ja nicht unbedingt immer konstant ist, sondern unter Umständen sich noch ein bisschen variiert.
Und eben bei jedem Wechsel natürlich sowieso.
Das heißt, es ist eher so ein bisschen Gefühlsache.
Also natürlich steht man sofort im Ding. Aber es gab schon gewisse Regeln, und das war schon ziemlich eindeutig festgelegt, wo ein Punkt zu sein hatte.
Ja gut, aber man kann es immer noch falsch machen. Man ist ja kein Datentypist, man ist ja ein Datenklickist sozusagen, der dann mit dieser Maus über diese Buchstaben rüberfährt.
Es gibt da genau diese Punkt-Sorten, bereits definiert, so wie sie heute auch kennen, und wie es auch in den BC-Kurven vorkommt. Es gibt den Eckpunkt, es gibt den Kurvenpunkt und es gibt den Tangentenpunkt. Wo eine Kurve übergeht in eine Gerade, da gibt es die Tangente. Damit diese Kurve aus der Linie Gerade herauskommt und nicht eine Delle oder eine Beule macht.
Gut, aber die gibt man ja nicht ein, sondern die wird dann daraus errechnet.
Die gibt man ein.
Man sagt, hier ist ja so ein Punkt.
Dieser Punkt ist ein Kurvenpunkt. Dieser Punkt ist ein Eckpunkt.
Aber man klickt nur die Punkte, die... Man kennt das ja auf dem Vektor-Grafik-Programm, wenn man die Bézier-Kurven anzeigen lässt, dann hat man Hilfslinien und Referenzpunkte, die links und rechts von der Linie liegen. Die klickt man jetzt hier nicht an, weil die gibt es ja in dem Sinne nicht. Man bleibt immer auf der Linie und sagt, hier ist ein Punkt, der relevant ist.
Man hat eine gezeichnete Buchstabenkontur und auf dieser Kontur liegen diese ganzen Punkte.
Und dann klickt man also drauf rum und die Software ist in der Lage, daraus ein mathematisches Modell auf Basis von Bezierkurven zu berechnen?
Ursprünglich war das Ding so gebaut. Diese Punkte wurden einfach digitalisiert in einen Lochstreifen. Genauso wie beim Fernschreiber oder bei irgendeinem Fadadadada. Alles das selbe System. Und das war eben gedacht für diesen Koordinatografen, der eben zu einem Schneidplotter ausgebaut worden war. Und dieser Schneidplotter konnte eben diese Punkte sozusagen ansteuern und dazwischen hin und her fahren und hatte auch einen Kurvenfahrbefehl eingebaut. Und wenn der eben diese 20 Punkte oder so, die da für einen Buchstaben notwendig sind, also sind es auch 50 oder 100 bei Komplizierten, und wenn der diese Punkte kommt, dann fährt er einfach von einem zum nächsten und weiß, er muss jetzt inzwischen ein Kreissegment fahren oder eine Gerade fahren. Also ursprünglich wurde das IKROS-System entwickelt, um Vorlagen für den Fotosatz zu schneiden.
Also um einen solchen Schneidplotter anzusteuern.
Um einen Schneidplotter anzusteuern.
Und dann hat man aber aus dieser mathematischen Beschreibung, die sich daraus ergeben hat, auch genauso die Bittemaps berechnen können. Für den Lichtsatz. Und später war das dann auch die Basis für?
Die ersten PostScript-Fonds.
Also die ersten Computer-Fonds. Jetzt sind wir aber im digitalen Zeitalter endlich angekommen. 80er Jahre. Da gab es dann die nächste Revolution im Druck. Unter dem Schlagwort Desktop Publishing wurde so der Traum geboren. Man könnte doch jetzt einfach nur unter Einsatz eines Personalcomputers den ganzen Druck auch irgendwie machen. Eine Vision, die voll aufgegangen ist, wie man heute feststellen darf. Also ich schätze mal 99,999% aller Druckerzeugnisse heutzutage werden auf diese Art und Weise erzeugt. Ich kann mich selber noch ganz gut erinnern über diese Übergangsphase, weil ich da so aushilfsmäßig in so einer Werbeagentur ein bisschen Computer-Support gegeben habe. Und dann saßen sie da halt alle noch mit ihren Scan-Grafik-Systemen. War das dann so ein Lichtsatzsystem? Ja, wahrscheinlich. Oder war das noch Fotosatz, nicht Scan-Grafik?
Das müsste schon ein Lichtsatzsystem sein.
Genau. Und alle waren so ein bisschen am Grübeln, ob denn das nun irgendwie sinnvoll ist, diese Computer zu kaufen, da mit dem Apfel drauf und so weiter. Ob denn das Zukunft hat und so. Harte Zukunft haben sie dann auch gekauft. Wie auch immer. Das Ganze ist fest verwoben mit einem Namen mit der Firma Adobe, die PostScript entworfen hat. Also diese Programmiersprache zur Beschreibung des Inhalts einer Seite. Und dazu gehörten halt grafische Elemente, Bitmaps, also Fotos, Linienformen, also Vektor-Beschreibungen. Und darauf aufbauend dann eben auch eine digitale Beschreibung von Fonts.
Schriften.
Schriften, Schriftarten, Touchfaces, was auch immer.
Das war der wesentliche Punkt für das frühe Postscript, dass man Schriften in Fotosatzqualität damals als Vergleich machen konnte. Also, dass das eben für grafische Programme so interessant war. Der gesamte Personalcomputer hatte eben seinen Ursprung in den Xerox-Forschungslabor. Und auch Apple hat dort einige Anleihen genommen, die aber auch weiterentwickelt. Und eines der ersten Programme, das dann eben für den Apple programmiert wurde, war von der kleinen Firma Aldus das Programm PageMaker. Das erste Testopublishing-Programm. Und Paul Brainard, der Gründer von Aldus, hat auch diesen Begriff geprägt. Also eben, dass man zu Hause am Schreibtisch alles machen kann, wozu man vorher ein Repro-Studio und ein komplettes Profisatzsystem, also irgendein Lichtsatzsystem, brauchte und eine Druckerei brauchte. Das sollte man alles zu Hause auf dem Schreibtisch machen können.
Und einen Setzer.
Also Setzer musste man dann selber sein. So viel musste man sich selber weiterbilden.
Also man brauchte keinen Setzer mehr, man konnte selber der Setzer werden.
Man musste selber der Setzer werden.
Ja, man musste auch, natürlich.
Ja, sonst ging es ja nicht. Wichtig daran ist eigentlich diese Verquickung von diesen ganzen Firmen. Also Apple macht einen Computer mit einer grafischen Benutzeroberfläche, wo man dann auch Schriften sehen kann. Das war ja damals noch sehr neu und ungewöhnlich, dass ein Computer da war, wo der Hintergrund nicht schwarz war und die Schrift grün drauf, sondern das Ganze war zumindest schwarz-weiß. Und es konnte die Schriftart geändert werden. Das zweite war dann eben die Firma Aldus, die genau diese Vision verfolgte, man sollte, wenn man am Computer eben mit Texten gestaltet, nicht, wie man es heute zum Beispiel aus HTML noch kennt, in Klammer B, Klammer zu, dann das Wort und wieder einen abschließenden Befehl, um das Fett abzuschließen, eingehen müssen, sondern man sollte das einfach sehen können, eine visuelle Kontrolle haben über das Aussehen der endgültigen Seite. Und die Firma Adobe hat eben mit PostScript und in weiterer Folge mit PDF die Grundlagen für die grafische Seitenbeschreibung gelegt. Und die Firma Linotype hat einen ihrer Belichter, also eines dieser Lichtsatzsysteme damals, das bereits auch schon mit Lasern funktioniert hat, eben mit einem PostScript-Treiber ausgerüstet und somit eben den Kreislauf geschlossen.
Und zum RIP, wie man das damals nannte?
RIP ist der Raster Image Processor. Das ist eigentlich ein Computer, der zwischen dem Macintosh und dem eigentlichen Belichter liegt. Es hat übrigens jeder normale Laserdrucker, hat genauso ein RIP eingebaut, der einfach aus den Daten, die der Computer eben herüberschickt, die Bitmap berechnet. Also Leser an, Leser aus, die Karte für den Drucker, der dem sagt, wie er das ganze pünktchenweise zu Papier bringen kann.
Ja, das war dann natürlich auch die Geburtsstunde der Computerfonds. Wir haben es ja schon erwähnt. Also der Mac war der erste, der so proportionale Schriften und sowas konnte.
Also in der ersten Version noch nicht. Genau, das ist ja das Lustige daran. Also Mac OS 1, also dann mit dem ersten Laserdrucker war es so, die Schriften da drauf waren nur Bitmaps, aber eben die Geneva würde dann im Druck in Areal herauskommen, wo aber die Areal oder Helvetica eben im Laserdrucker erst eingebaut war und noch nicht im Computersystem. Das war dann erst in der zweiten Generation, wo dann auch Apple eben die Postscript-Schriften ins Betriebssystem übernommen hat. Also das Lustige ist...
Du meinst jetzt Mac OS 10?
Na, Mac OS 2 oder was, 1985, 86.
Das haben sie ja nie gemacht, sondern Adobe hat ja diesen Type Manager sozusagen installiert.
Nee, nee, funktioniert haben die Schriften immer. Die Kantenklettung hat nicht funktioniert. Also die, dass die Postscript-Schriften verwendet waren, das war relativ von Anfang an, bei diesem Streit ging es um die Kantenklettung. Also das war schon wieder auch ein ganzes Stückchen später. Nachdem das ja am Anfang so war, die Seitenbeschreibungssprache Postscript war offen verfügbar, war ein offener Standard, also dokumentierter Standard. Aber für die Schriften wollte Adobe Lizenzen, Lizenzgebühren haben. Also für jede Postschrift von jedem Hersteller, die verkauft wurde, hätte Adobe Lizenzen bekommen sollen. Und weder Microsoft noch Apple wollten das. Und so haben sie gesagt, wir machen unser eigenes Schriftenformat. Das nennen wir TrueType. Dieses Format wurde übrigens von Apple entwickelt, 1989 angekündigt und 1992 herausgekommen. Und ist aber dann eben unter Windows bekannter geworden, weil Microsoft TrueType mehr beworben hat als Apple selbst, obwohl es eben von Apple entwickelt wurde. Ist eben vom technischen Standart überhaupt kein Unterschied zu PostScript. Ist ein bisschen andere Mathematik. Hat aber auf jeden Fall den Effekt gehabt, den es auch haben sollte. Nämlich Adobe hat die Spezifikationen für die Postscript-Schriften freigegeben. Und es konnte also jeder Postscript-Schriften verkaufen, der wollte.
Aber vorher war es ein bisschen schwierig, weil die Type-1-Fonds, es gab ja nicht nur ein Postscript-Fond-Format, sondern es gab die sogenannten Type-1-Fonds und dann gab es auch noch Type-3, ich weiß nicht, gab es auch noch ein Type-2?
Gab es sicher, ja.
Ich habe noch nie ein Type-2-Fond gesehen. Ich weiß noch, Type-3-Fonds waren so ganz fancy, wo noch so Programmierung mit drin sein konnte, die sich noch selbst modifiziert haben beim Druck, oder selbst angepasst haben.
Das war etwas anderes. Bei Type-3 konnte man den gesamten Postscript-Code verwenden, in der Schrift. Das war auch von Anfang an freigegeben. Das Font-Format, weil es eben nicht geeignet ist für Mengensatz. Man konnte zum Beispiel auch ein Bild hineinladen in eine Schrift, in einem Type-3-Font. Type-1-Font hatte eben diese berühmten Sachen wie Hinting, wo eben zum Beispiel Verbesserungen zur Sichtbarkeit oder zur Lesbarkeit am Bildschirm oder bei schlechten Drucksystemen drin waren. Normalerweise, wenn man einen Buchstaben in Pixeln aufrastet, dann müsste man viel Glück haben, wenn man zufällig dieselbe Strichstärke bei allen, zum Beispiel beim Haar, beim linken und beim rechten, senkrechten und beim waagrechten Balken, wenn man das zwölf Pixel hoch macht, also dass das so regelmäßig würde. Diese zusätzlichen Informationen in der Schrift, die eben genau das bewirken, dass die Schrift einheitlich aussieht, also nicht nur im Bildschirm, sondern auch eben im Druck. Das war diese spezielle Programmeigenschaft der PostScript Type-1-Fonds, die Adobe eben nicht freigeben wollte, zumindest anfänglich nicht, also erst unter dem Druck von TrueType.
Aber TrueType hat sich ja dann doch schon so ein bisschen zum universalen Schriftformat entwickelt, vor allem weil es sich auch unter Windows so gut durchgesetzt hat, weil Microsoft das zum Einsatz gebracht hat, auf Mac eigentlich auch. Trotzdem hat es natürlich diverse Beschränkungen gehabt, wo am Anfang noch nicht so viele Leute darauf geachtet haben. So war der ganze Zeichenvorrat auch nur 8-bit. Also man konnte dann nur so auf 256 Zeichen schöpfen. Und das ist natürlich so in der heutigen Zeit, wo Unicode, also dieses universelle, der universelle, wie sagt man so, schöne Codeset, also die gesamte Zusammenfassung aller druckbaren Zeichen, doch nicht druckbaren Zeichen, in einem einzigen Alphabet, was natürlich mit 256 Zeichen nicht ausdient, irgendwann ist dann dieses OpenType entstanden. Das ist jetzt ein paar Jahre her. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange gibt es das schon, OpenType?
1996. Das war wiederum die Allianz zwischen Adobe und Microsoft. Der Vorteil für Adobe ist ganz klar, sie haben ein Containerformat, das sowohl PostScript als auch TrueType-Outlines versteht. Der Unterschied ist minimal und reine Mathematik, also von der Funktionalität völlig identisch. Also Adobe hätte Systemunterstützung gehabt für seine Schriften. Außerdem wollten sie ein gemeinsames Format machen, das sowohl auf Max-VR als auch auf PCs lauffähig ist. Der wesentliche Unterschied zu den vorherigen Systemen ist außerdem noch das, dass OpenType bestimmte Intelligenz vorzuweisen hat. Es gibt hier eben die Unterscheidung von Character und Glyph oder wissenschaftlich formuliert von Signifikanter und Significator oder auf Deutsch von Zeichenbedeutung und Zeichenform, dass das getrennt sein kann und zwar in einer Schrift. Beispiel? Das betrifft z.B. Ligaturen. Wenn F und L aufeinander folgen, dann ist das eine eigene Form. Die Rechtschreibprüfung weiß aber trotzdem, dass das F und L sind.
Also der Glyph ist sozusagen das verschmolzene F oder das L?
Die Form und die Bedeutung ist aber nicht viel, sondern F und L. Bei den alten Systemen war das ja so, bei PostScript und TrueType gab es auch eine Glyph, eine eigene Form für F und L. Das war aber tatsächlich nur eine eigene Nummer. Bei der ganzen Codierung geht es immer nur um Nummern. Man nummeriert das Alphabet einmal durch, bzw. den Zeichenvorrat, den man haben möchte. Diese Nummern sind für einen Computer wichtig, weil er bekanntlich mit Zeichen nichts anfangen kann, sondern nur mit Zahlen.
Aber in OpenType sind ja auch noch andere Features. Unicode haben wir schon gesagt.
Es können tatsächlich alle Schriftsysteme weltweit in einem Fund vorkommen. Wenn man sich den System-Fund unter Windows oder Mac OS X anschaut, dann sieht man ja, das fängt irgendwo an bei lateinischen Schriftzeichen, geht dann über Chirilisch, Russisch, Arabisch, Chinesisch und was dann da alles kommen kann. Das kann alles in einer Schrift vorkommen und ist eindeutig zugewiesen. Es kann keine von diesen lustigen Verwechslungen mehr auftreten, wie das früher immer war, wenn man nur einen Text vom Mac auf den PC geschoben hat und alle Sonderzeichen verwirfelt wurden. Das ist ja so ein typisches Codierungsproblem.
Das wird auch erst sehr langsam überwunden. Teilweise mithilfe des Internets, teilweise hilft auch das Internet nicht sehr viel weiter. Aber OpenType befindet sich heute in aktiver Unterstützung. Mac OS X-Unterschützer, Windows.
Seit 2002.
Ist das ein XP auch schon fest mit eingebaut?
Der Standard wurde 1996 festgelegt und eingebaut seit 2002. Und trotzdem wissen viele Leute noch nicht, dass es nicht mehr TrueType ist. Obwohl, wie gesagt, das ist zum Teil streng genommen, ist es ja TrueType. Die mathematische Beschreibung der Kurven, also der Vektoren, ist nach wie vor TrueType. Aber eben dieses zweiteilige Verfahren von Character und Cliff, das ist neu. Und das hat für viele Sachen einen Vorteil. Es gibt zum Beispiel jetzt eben neue Schriften, die sogenannte stilistische Alternativen haben, die man dann in dem jeweiligen Programm auswählen kann, die das unterstützt. Also auf jeden Fall alle Adobe-Programme natürlich.
Ist das dieses Multiple Master-Font, was du jetzt gerade ansprichst? Das hatte ich irgendwie jetzt noch im Hinterkopf.
Multiple Master ist ein Format, das von Adobe entwickelt wurde dazwischen. Das haben die dann auch aufgegeben. Das beruhte also auf PostScript. Und man konnte also in einer Schrift, zum Beispiel, sozusagen, es waren zwei Schriften in einer Schrift gespeichert oder konnten gespeichert werden können, zum Beispiel Fett und DIN. Und man konnte dann in den jeweiligen Programmen sozusagen einen Schieberegler und konnte das stufenlos einstellen, wie man die Schrift wollte. Ein bisschen fetter oder doch ein bisschen dünner. Und also von der Idee her, grundsätzlich super Ansatz, aber wurde damals eben nicht genug beworben. Und hätte vielleicht auch sogar den Durchschnittsgrafiker überfordert, das den normalen Computer-Manager sowieso völlig überfordert. Und wird auch wahrscheinlich die nächsten zehn Jahre noch da bleiben, wenn man sich das geschichtlich anschaut. PostScript 84, OpenType 96. Und was anderes war auf dem Computermarkt eigentlich nicht da. Also TrueType ist...
Genau, und OpenType ist ja eigentlich noch dabei, sich erst so richtig durchzusetzen.
Und es hat schon viele angenehme, also kleine Gags eingebaut, eben diese automatische Wechseln von allen möglichen Sachen, das man einbauen kann. Also eben wie gesagt, die Schrift hat eine gewisse eigene Intelligenz und macht automatische Digiturn Ersetzungen, was bei uns in lustigen Schreibschriften resultiert, die sich dann automatisch austauschen. Was aber zum Beispiel für Arabisch grundsätzlich wichtig ist, weil das eine wesentlich kaligraphischere Schriftsprache ist.
Aber wenn man so einen Font jetzt kauft, dann bedeutet das ja nicht, dass auch gleich alle Sprachen damit drin sind.
Das ist eigentlich nur bei den Systemschriften, bei sonst gar keiner.
Gibt es denn da eigentlich auch irgendeine Automatik? Also ich habe immer so dieses Problem, also was heißt, ich habe immer das Problem, aber ich kann mir das Problem erstens ganz gut vorstellen. Man will halt einen Text in unterschiedlichen Sprachen haben, so auch auf Webseiten wird das langsam so ein Thema. Man hat so verschiedene Lokalisierung und Übersetzung, und man möchte jetzt irgendwie aber auch sicherstellen, dass man immer einen Font hat. Und jetzt ist es so, wenn ich mir hier irgendwie in meinem Webbrowser so eine Seite anschaue, dann habe ich halt dann doch, wenn das jetzt irgendwie so eine total abgefahrene Sprache ist, was weiß ich, Georgisch, habe ich halt keine georgischen Glyphen vor meiner Nase, sondern einfach nur so Kästchen. Gibt es da irgendwie auch so Methoden, um zu sagen, wenn, keine Ahnung, ägyptische Hieroglyphen oder wenn georgische Zeichen kommen, dann schalte ich halt automatisch um auf diesen Font, weil der hat das.
Das wäre wieder eine Sache vom Browser.
Ich meine, gibt es da so eine Art Meta-Font-Konzept in OpenType, dass man sagen kann, für diesen Codeset irgendwie blende automatisch die Zeichen von einem anderen ein und das Programm muss gar nichts davon wissen? Gibt es nicht?
Im Normalfall gibt es etliche dieser Ersatzsysteme. Also eines der frühesten ist zum Beispiel das Pannosesystem. Das ist auch in Windows eingebaut, das automatisch, aber für gesamte fehlende Schriften, nicht für einzelne Zeichen. Von Adobe war im Adobe TypeManager so ein System eingebaut zum Beispiel. Und grundsätzlich ist es eben eine Frage der Codierung, welche Zeichen drinnen sind und welche nicht, weil auch bei einer falschen Codierung kann das selbe Problem auftreten.
Ja, aber meine Unicode ist ja eigentlich recht wohl sortiert, wenn man da sich mal durch die Codeset-Tabellen durchklickt und so sieht man irgendwie so, jetzt fängt ein neuer Blog an und hier ist jetzt irgendwie georgisch und hier haben wir die hier und hier haben wir irgendwie indisch, tralala.
Um solche Probleme zu umgehen, würde ich einfach im Browser einstellen, dass immer Systemschriften alles überschreiben, weil die normalen Systemschriften enthalten auf jeden Fall alle einigermaßen normalen Glyphen. Also jeder Schriftwort.
Leider auch nicht alle, aber viele.
Zumindest wird ein.
Gibt es eigentlich schon so freie Fonts, die was taugen?
Zum Beispiel Gentium ist vom SIL, sil.org.
sil.org? Gentium, so heißt der Font?
So heißt der Font von Victor Goldnay. Also es gibt schon einige, also eher aus dem wissenschaftlichen Bereich, wie hier, gibt es durchaus komplette Schriften, die auch gratis sind, weil gratis Schriften finden wir ja gerade nicht wenig am Netz, aber eben besonders vollständige sind schon eher selten. Und bevor du das Metafont angesprochen hast, da gab es ja auch das Metafont-Format von Donald Knuth. Das war ja auch eines der ersten, tatsächlich Computersysteme für Schrift, wobei das eben den Nachteil hat, dass es nicht im Rahmen einer Programmiersprache stattfindet. Dafür aber eben, wie das Multiple-Master-Format die Möglichkeit hat, den einzelnen Buchstaben zu variieren. Das heißt, Knuth hatte da das lustige Konzept, man macht sozusagen ein Skelett jedes Buchstabens, eine Linie und fährt diese Linie mit einem Werkzeug nach, also mit einem Stift. Und dieser Stift kann unterschiedliche Formen annehmen und kann sich glaube ich auch drehen entlang dieser Linie. Das heißt, man kann dann eben von einer Grundform, eben unter Programmiertechnische Unterstützung einen ganzen Haufen Variationen rausholen. Das Unangenehme daran ist, es gibt kein Programm mit grafischer Benutzeroberfläche dafür und man muss also tatsächlich für jeden Buchstab ein eigenes Programm schreiben, was für einen Mathematiker kein Problem ist, aber für einen normalen Menschen doch. Und das Ganze ist eben eingebaut in Tech und LaTeX und wie die ganzen mathematischen Beschreibungssprachen hier heißen. Und das einzige, wo die Computermodern von Knut noch vorkommt heutzutage, würde ich sagen, ist in ernsthaften mathematischen Veröffentlichungen, die man dann sofort von allem anderen unterscheiden kann, weil sie diese sehr spezifische Schrift verwenden. Die meisten die Computermodern.
Genau, die erkennt man immer in so Techpapers. Die ist sehr besonders. Aber Knut hat sich ja im Prinzip auch als Typesetter verstanden. Der hat ja dieses System auch wirklich den Gesichtspunkt von Schriftsatz entwickelt.
Aber nach heutigen Standards, also wie sich die Entwicklung eben, wie wir sie schon aufgerollt haben, ergeben hat, ist PostScript der Standard. Und wenn Metafont nicht irgendwie ein gutes Interface hat zu PostScript, beziehungsweise zu OpenType, dann ist es heute nicht im Rahmen des Systems.
Ja, also ich meine, Tech hat schon immer so ein bisschen seine eigene Welt definiert. Aber für viele Leute, gerade im mathematischen Bereich, um eine Formel zu setzen, ist es natürlich viel, viel einfacher, da mit Tech ranzugehen. Nicht nur, ich meine, es hat ja auch eine ganze Menge andere Qualitäten, die jetzt so im wörtprozessigen Bereich sind. Ich meine, ich habe früher auch extrem viele Techs geschrieben, bis mir dann irgendwie Adobe meine Lieblings-Techs-Verarbeitung geklaut hat, nämlich Framemaker, die immer noch total unerreicht ist, die es zwar unter Windows noch gibt, aber das benutze ich nicht. Und so auf Mac gibt es das halt nicht. Und alle anderen Programme erreichen also noch nicht mal im Ansatz den Standard, den ich da irgendwie schon vor, na, was haben wir jetzt, 2008. Na ja, also vor 10, 15 Jahren, da hatte.
Ich schreibe immer im Texteditor eigentlich.
Ja gut, aber eine Formel macht man natürlich da noch nicht so eben.
Nee, aber das brauche ich glücklicherweise ja nicht.
Ich eigentlich auch selten. Um ehrlich zu sein, ich werde nicht so tun, als wäre ich Mathematiker. Eigentlich habe ich schon Mathematiker, keine Ahnung. Wie auch immer. Ich wollte sagen, in Text sind halt auch eine ganze Menge Sachen drin, die einfach für eine Textverarbeitung, also für das Schreiben von großen Dokumenten sehr wichtig sind. Fußnoten, um ein ganz einfaches Beispiel zu nennen, Inhaltsverzeichnis automatisch erstellen. Klar, das können heutzutage auch alle Textverarbeitungsprogramme, aber so richtig gut und einfach ist es in den seltensten Fällen. Geschweige denn, dass die Dinger irgendwie ordentlich performen, wenn man wirklich riesige Dokumente hat. Das sind natürlich solche Sachen ganz gut. Mal gucken, welche Rolle da Text spielt. Da muss ich aber wahrscheinlich noch mal einen eigenen Podcast zu dem Thema aufrufen. Allein um mich selbst mit dem Thema noch ein bisschen mehr zu verheiraten. Wir haben jetzt die Technikgeschichte durchgespult des Buchdrucks oder des Drucks an sich von Zeichen. Von Gutenberg bis zur OpenType. Ich bin beeindruckt. Super Themenablauf hier. Hast du denn noch ein letztes Wort, was wir unbedingt gesagt haben müssen, bevor wir uns von unseren Hörern verabschieden können?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Wir sind durch. Du hast eine Diplomarbeit geschrieben, aber die ist noch nicht fertig.
Die ist noch nicht ganz fertig und die wird in Endeffekt auch mal als Buch herauskommen.
Wird die dann auch im Internet veröffentlicht oder ist das dann erstmal geheim? Was machen wir denn so mit Diplomarbeiten heutzutage?
Bis sie abgenommen ist, muss sie geheim bleiben. Wenn sie dann veröffentlicht wird, wird sie wahrscheinlich erst einmal als Buch veröffentlicht werden. Was mir auch ganz wichtig ist, weil es geht ja um den Druck von Buchstaben in Büchern, und es ist ja natürlich auch jede Menge Abbildungsmaterial mit dabei, wenn man viele der Sachen natürlich nur versteht, wenn man die entsprechende Skizze hat.
In welchem System wirst du es dann setzen?
Ich setze momentan noch unter OS 9. Das wird jetzt viele sehr schockieren, zwar auch das Szenesystem vom zweiten Gerät, aber von der Bearbeitungsgeschwindigkeit ist mein altes Layout-Programm immer noch um Längen vorne.
Quakexpress nehme ich an.
Altes Quakexpress. Also Vierer, Fünfer. Auch richtig. Aber das geht richtig schnell.
Ja, was man gut kann, ist meistens schneller als das, was man nicht so gut kann.
Ja, das ist ja zehn Jahre Übung. Ja, das stimmt.
Ja, super. Da freuen wir uns drauf. Vielleicht findet ja auch ein gewisser Subaspekt hier auch noch mal Eingang in einen interessanten Vortrag auf dem Chaos-Communication-Kongress. Kann ich dich nur dazu einladen. Da hat Technikgeschichte auf jeden Fall immer seinen Platz. Ist auch ein sehr dankbares Publikum. Ja, und liebes Publikum, das war's. Der Podcast über Typografie und über Drucktechnik. Und ich bedanke mich bei dir, Thomas, für die umfangreichen Ausführungen. Und von euch möchte ich natürlich jetzt wissen, ob ihr es wirklich geschafft habt, euch durch diesen Marathon-Podcast durchzuhangeln. Über zwei Stunden sind es geworden, aber ich denke, sehr ergiebig, sehr interessant. Wie immer fordere ich euch auf Zu-Kommentaren in unserem Blog, blogchaosradio.ccc.de oder schreibt uns eine E-Mail at chaosradio.ccc.de und wir nehmen uns das alles wie immer sehr zu Herzen. Und das war's. Und ich sage Tschüss, vielen Dank nochmal, Thomas, und bis bald bei Chaos Radio Express.